all right welcome friends and haters
trolls and supporters I guess sort of
encompasses everybody it's night two of
two the first presidential debate split
up because of so many candidates into
two nights tonight is the night with
most of the frontrunner Joe Biden is in
tonight's debate Bernie Sanders Pete
Budaj edge who I am hoping to see
substance from and we'll talk about that
are we going to see any policy from Pete
Buddha judge in detail beyond just
generalities which has been a sort of
weak point of the Buddha judge campaign
so far in my completely honest and and
frank opinion so a few things to talk
about number one we have removed we have
removed yesterday's live stream coverage
from YouTube people emailing me saying
David did it get taken down it did not
get taken down we were told about a lot
of different youtubers getting 90 day
bans from live streaming with copyright
strikes for videos that included the NBC
live stream from yesterday in addition
to their commentary and I was going back
and forth with Sam cedar and with others
today and I made the decision to
preemptively take the take the thing
down and it's a disappointing thing
because it had like a hundred thousand
views it was actually monetized it was
generating revenue for us it had some
funny moments it was a great thing but
the risk was just too great and we have
relatively little or no power to push
back against these things unless we want
to go through you know sometimes a
multi-week appeal process and by that
point you know we haven't been able to
stream for weeks and weeks at a time so
we took the video down and I don't know
we didn't delete it we just took it off
lot we made it private for the time
being so I don't know maybe it'll go
back up and I don't even know what we're
going to do with the archive of today's
show I actually expect that there may be
even more viewers tonight in general for
this debate then yesterday because
yesterday's debate generated a lot of
interest and a lot of the big players
are in tonight to rehash my sense of the
un-- by the way let me I'll just go
straight over to the shot that we will
be used
during the during the debate and you'll
see me and you'll see super chats which
you can start sending in and you'll see
the debate itself and you'll see the
coupon code that is available for
membership I thought that yesterday the
top three winners of the debate were not
in necessarily any particular order
Elizabeth Warren bill de blasio and who
Leon Castro now Castro and de Blasio are
not people that I've said are my top
contenders this is just sort of as
objective and analysis as possible of my
sense of how they did I like Elizabeth
Warren more than the other two de Blasio
I thought did very well in the debate
although I am NOT becoming a de Blasio
supporter and actually I really did like
who Leon Castro not only because of how
he performed but also a lot of the
things he said I mean the guy has a
really deep knowledge of issues that are
important to him immigration being one
of them and somebody said what about a
warren a castro ticket and it's way too
early to even talk about that but i
would not be I would much rather who
Leon Castro as a running mate than
several of the other candidates that we
saw last night many people last night
just they really need to go I mean I
don't know how much longer they're going
to stay and if they don't start polling
better I got a bunch of emails from
people saying David did you see the poll
on such-and-such comm where tulsi
dominated or a poll where supposedly it
was a Cory Booker who won the debate we
are not going to know the real effect of
the debate last night's and tonight's
until the middle of next week more than
likely I'm guessing tomorrow and over
the weekend pollsters will start
actually doing properly sampled polls
that take into account how people
believe the debates went and I don't
think we're going to know anything about
who is actually going to benefit the
winners and losers from last night
until next week other than I think bado
lost big big big big and to address so I
talked earlier today and yesterday about
how I thought Beto's speaking of Spanish
was a total disaster and a few people
wrote to me and they said David you know
in an era of anti-intellectualism and
pseudo-intellectual ISM shouldn't we be
encouraging candidates to speak more
than one language remember when the
made fun of John Kerry because he spoke
French and we rightly said no it's good
to have presidents that are educated in
worldly I completely agree my problem is
not that bata O'Rourke speaks some
Spanish or that he values being able to
communicate with Latino voters who speak
Spanish in their language I think that's
all great the problem is if someone says
to you what do you think the top
marginal tax rate should be and you go
into a state economy ax and nuestro
democracia which are not even
grammatically correct something is very
wrong in that it seems like pandering
because it is you're not answering the
question so I have no problem with
people speaking other languages with
peace and love speak as many languages
as you want and and I think that's great
the criticism was that the way it was
done was it didn't seem genuine it
seemed pre-calculated and there was just
nothing nothing good about it okay let's
see what am I going to be paying
attention to today a few different
things and I decided yet people told me
that yesterday I was taking notes on my
laptop below for the commentary for
today's show and a bunch of people said
it was just my typing was distracting I
mean I know half the people in the chat
will probably say they didn't notice any
typing but today I've decided to bring
out one of my various yellow pads and
I'm gonna be writing on paper just to
appease people who didn't like the the
typing so a few things that I'm going to
be looking for tonight and then I'm
gonna get super chats and then we're
only about 12 minutes away from the
start of this thing number one how does
the rest of the field tonight treat Joe
Biden okay
because Biden is both one of the more
centrist candidates and according to
every poll basically maybe one shows
them within the margin of error of
second-place basically the the
front-runner right now so is he going to
be attacked hard by the other people on
the stage and if so is it by the people
who really have nothing to lose the
zeros and ones as I call them or are the
other frontrunners going to attack Joe
Biden like Bernie Sanders or people you
to judge or whoever else that's number
one number two how much does Bernie
Sanders
take credit for the mainstreaming of
ideas that certainly lots of people on
the stage will pay lip service to well
Bernie Sanders actually say I love that
all of you have come around to X policy
I was talking about it in 2016 when none
of you were in favor of it I'm
interested in seeing that number three
is Pete Buddha judge going to give a
substance now the problem with these
debates is that with ten people on the
stage one minute answers and 30-second
rebuttals only some candidates even get
to give a minute answer only some
candidates even get to rebut each answer
it is not an environment that actually
encourages any depth and a lot of
candidates as a result can get away with
saying nothing talking for 75 seconds
and saying nothing and getting cut off
by the moderators so hopefully we will
get a sense of whether Pete Buddha judge
has some more specific policy ideas that
he can articulate it in a serious and
unproductive way and then are there any
breakouts like for me yesterday I was
not thinking of Bill DeBlasio at all in
part one I was barely thinking about who
Yann Castro at all in part one but they
both impressed me in terms of their
debate performance de Blasio still has
no chance and Castro has almost no
chance but I'm going to be interested in
following that and Andrew yang the only
presidential candidate I guess I've
interviewed marianne williamson and
she's being allowed on the stage but
she's you know anyway I'm interested to
see how Andrew yang does and I actually
do believe that he is someone that as
people become aware of him he really
could see a boost to his poll numbers in
the next week if he doesn't he's
probably done as well there's a lot of
people that in a week probably will be
able to safely get out of this thing and
we'll see who those are in just a few
days so let's see what else
memberships yes we we had the most
amazing thing happened yesterday during
the live stream yesterday new members
were coming in roughly every few minutes
okay every few minutes there was a new
member to the point where I couldn't
even keep up this morning I woke up and
I looked I have a folder all member
related emails payments cancellations
new subscriptions anytime anything comes
in it
assured into a separate gmail folder and
I had 1,200 unread messages related to
membership some are just payments that
were due on the 20 whatever but the 27th
of the month but a lot of new
subscriptions yesterday let's do it
again let's do it again today and
another thing that I am thinking of is
yesterday I accidentally if you're
looking at the live chat on the side
over I guess over there on most screens
or maybe down there on mobile it gets
going so fast there's 2,500 people
watching right now yesterday when we had
70 300 it was moving so quickly that it
almost became useless now I don't want
to censor people it's great for people
to be able to type their comments in but
I accidentally turned on a feature
called
only channel members may send messages
and when I did it only people who have
hit the join button down below or over
there over there depending where you're
watching only channel members were
allowed to comment and it got so quiet
and peaceful and a whole bunch of our
paid subscribers on the YouTube channel
got in touch and said David that was
amazing and as soon as I turned it on
all sorts of new YouTube members started
popping up so what I may do tonight I
don't know if it'll be that first half
hour maybe we'll do it at the end of the
first hour of the debate or maybe we
will do like a 15 or 30 minute period
where only YouTube channel subscribers
will be allowed to comment in the chat
will be allowed to chat and we'll see
what happens I mean even just by me
mentioning it Corey Harrison now has
signed up as you can see over there so
anyway that's something I'm thinking of
trying um and what else I don't know
what else I guess that's mostly it let's
take a look at some of the super chats
and people's I made the super chat a
little bit bigger and hopefully
everybody can see it okay let's see what
we had come in today I want to find the
beginning for this evening it might have
been Wow a lot of super chats already
had okay Alicia right PhD sent us a
$2.00 super chat which is very nice
raagh nut ssbm says how you doing my guy
I'm doing well and I am ready for
tonight Bryan Ferran Miami Dolphins
analytics says I'm excited to see
Gillibrand tonight my number one choice
I forgot she was even to be
and she should probably exit the race
very very soon Jimmy from Philly says
Trump 2020 it's inevitable okay Jimmy
hey hates progressives loves Trump and
he contributes to the show so if Jimmy
does it we should all be able to do it J
Brian and pay ha Anderson say Andrew
yang is who we need Adam Barnes says
yang Bernie Warren or Pete I ain't picky
Sabrina so far says detailed thoughts on
response to Gabbard listen people who
are in the Gabbard cult loved it they
thought she won I think that she was
thrown a bone by the bone headedness of
Tim Ryan if Tim Ryan doesn't start
talking about the Taliban doing 9/11
Tulsi has zero good moments her first
answer was just crazy I mean it was I
don't even know what what the question
was but her answer was I was in the
military so I think that she I think she
was tied for fifth yesterday I think she
didn't do particularly well but she
didn't have any major gaffes and she
might get a point there to maybe which
would probably encourage her supporters
to say she's gonna win but much ado
about nothing a big picture Quinn ik's
yoshiyama says our Bernie is going to
steamroll everyone tonight
Thomas Milner says ubi is far better
than a $15 minimum wage
Daniel Krieger says David did you notice
Tulsi call out Saudi Arabia for
sponsoring terrorism for a split second
before getting cut off this is extremely
important I did her hear her say Saudi
Arabia yes Val McLin she you're the best
David will you open the phones tonight I
might I might if if we have overwhelming
membership support I might do it it's
been a tiring few days it really has
okay it looks like what is going on here
I guess the candidates are standing at
the stage Andrew yang third Marianne
Williamson on the left we're minutes
from the debate and let's see her is
anything happening he is
front runner here and he is the person
that everyone's gonna be gunning for no
I agree and I think I will get to it as
soon as it starts but I want to I want
to keep doing super chats for now Wiesn
as with the top super chat of the
evening but not of all time 99.99 i used
to be a republican and voted for Trump
you changed me
thank you very much wheezing as I
appreciate that Mick Mundy can't wait
for yang to bring that US national
debate team experience he's mentioned
very hopeful for tonight picturing my
love says should also live stream on
Twitch can't trust YouTube yeah but you
can't
Simon and YouTube is the problem
David one of my yellow various yellow
pads Hackman says experience music
wiesen as with a second 9999 super chat
I miss Pat and don't let YouTube get you
down Kathy H with a super chap Tom
Langford says a bit random but I love
your t-shirt David Thank You Devon Young
says I lost what Devon Young said where
is Devon young Devon young is there I
want to have wiesen as money alright let
me turn this up because it seems like we
are close the challenge of both
introducing herself to the American
public for folks who haven't seen our
story also alright I'll just keep it low
for now a couple new members Corey
Harrison and the arts origins and tall
tale says hello excited for tonight nice
shirt a shirt is popular Nick Newcomb
and Alessio szostak are new members
Matt H just graduated from high school
30 minutes ago and sends a dollar 99
congratulations Phil Romero tons of
super chat and rule in court do it again
it keeps the mag of losers out if
nothing else only members only a chat
stream kg has signed up Dylan
Tyler David would you recommend any
Republican political Republican
political commentators that you respect
and feel our level-headed and honest I
like hearing both sides you know I
wouldn't deal and I wouldn't I'm sure
you can find them I don't need to be
recommending any other Kaiba Corp HQ
says feel the Bern feel the Bern
Alice McCain sends a dollar Rory drew as
a new member Ian mulrennan
since two dollars thanks for being
awesome David loop choice is a new
member
let's see here the Death Star says who
do you think will win David got a watch
I don't know grapple scrapple says my
top three goes Bernie yang Warren what's
yours those are really my favorite three
candidates not necessarily in any we're
getting close here I'm keeping an eye on
it a projects and sanity says Trump 2020
is inevitable if progressives are
progressives continue to ignore facts
being disclosed over classified why do
you continue to suppress these facts I
don't know what you're talking about
I know what on earth Karam Elmer tag
sends a supercut Alice McCain is a new
member kait gauri says to Simon stream
YouTube and twitch you need restream yes
but twitch does not allow you to do it I
believe you can't earn money on twitch
if you're doing Kaylee Bracken's bernie
is the only one who will make it fail
mark turi is a new member Mike K loves
the show fYI you are showing up in my
YouTube newsfeed that is good news
potentially because David bit toe says
taking a shot every time a candidate
dunks on Biden might be passed out
before this is over
you could be passed out by Oh 9:20 p.m.
Eastern Time depending on how this goes
number 4 20 pencil says support
independent media Michael Berg DC is a
new member and it scrolled down I'm not
doing that on purpose just when a bunch
of things come in at once it'll scrote
scroll down violence Rob not Bob sends a
dollar
Devon young sends $1 Jacobus is a new
member
PDX pro courier tips and tricks' says
when will we see Pat guest host the show
feed him very good question Brian Howard
heat her the hash tag boom Shakalaka
brings back memories of playing NBA Jam
when I was 10 Joe Rollins says Gang Gang
is welcome looking forward to your
supporting Bernie remember even yang
supported Bernie in 2020 negative income
tax is not GM I all right it's time
let's see what's happening here
that's me getting a spam call I
apologize about that
nothing is frozen it just seems as
though
good evening I'm Lester Holt and welcome
to night two of the first democratic
debate in the 2020 race for president
evening Savannah Guthrie last night we
heard from ten candidates and now ten
more take the stage
tonight we'll be joined to the
questioning by our colleagues Jose Diaz
Maillard Chuck Todd and Rachel Maddow
the candidates are in position so let's
get started tonight
round two Colorado Senator Michael
Bennet former Vice President Joe Biden
South Bend Indiana mayor de puta James
New York senator Kirsten Gillibrand via
California senator Kamala Harris former
Colorado Governor John Hickenlooper
among senator Bernie Sanders California
Congressman Eric's whoa whoa no chatter
marianne williamson should have been out
long for executive andrew yeah all right
after them NBC News decision 2020
Democratic candidates debate
[Music]
here we go 7300 concurrent live
streamers was the top yesterday let's
see if we can beat it today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
across America tonight we continue this
spirited debate about the future of the
country how to tackle our most pressing
problems and getting to the heart of the
biggest issues in this Democratic
primary tonight we're going to talk
about health care immigration we're also
gonna dive into the economy jobs climate
change as well as some quick rules of
the road before we begin and they may
sound familiar 20 candidates Calvin
qualified for this first debate as we
said we heard from town last night and
we'll hear from ten more tonight the
breakdown for each night was selected at
random the candidates will have 60
seconds to answer the recent follow-ups
and because of the large field of
candidates not every person is going to
be able to weigh in on every topic but
over the course of the next two hours we
will hear from everyone and we love
audience but we'd like to ask them to
keep their reactions to a minimum and
we're not gonna hold back in making sure
the candidates stick to time so with
that business take care taken care of
let's get to it and we're gonna start
today with senator Sanders good evening
to you you've called for big new
government benefits like universal
health care and free college in a recent
interview you said you suspected that
Americans would be quote delighted to
pay more taxes for things like that my
question to you is will taxes go up for
the middle class in a Sanders
administration and if so how do you sell
that to those softball
you're quite boy we have a news ition
for America and at a time when we have
three people in this country owning more
wealth than the bottom half of America
while 500,000 people are sleeping out on
the streets today we think it is time
for change real change and by that I
mean that healthcare in my view is a
human right and we have got to pass a
medicare-for-all single-payer system
under that system is Murphy that's
majority of the people in this country
will be paying significantly less for
health care than they are right now I
believe that education is the future for
this country and that is why I believe
that we must make public colleges and
universities tuition-free and eliminate
student debt and we do that by placing a
tax on Wall Street that's a musket rifle
so that I have brought forth is fully
paid for ten seconds just to ask the
answer the very direct question will you
raise taxes for the middle class in the
Sanders administration people who have
health care on the Medicare for all will
have no premiums no deductibles no
co-payments no out of extra
out-of-pocket expenses yes they will pay
more in taxes but less in health care
for what they get promised everybody's
gonna get in here promised to Biden
senator Sanders as you know has been
calling for a revolution recently in
remarks to a group of wealthy donors as
you were speaking about the probably go
of income inequality in this country you
said we shouldn't quote demonize the
rich you said nobody has to be punished
no one's standard of living would change
nothing would fundamentally change what
did you mean by that not by that is look
Donald Trump thinks Wall Street pull
America ordinary middle-class Americans
build America my dad used to have an
expression C Joe a job was about a lot
more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect it's being able to look your kid
in the eye and said everything's going
to be okay too many people who are in
the middle class and poor have at the
bottom fall out under this proposal too
low saying is that we've got to be
straightforward
we have to make sure we understand that
the return dignity to the middle class
they have to have insurance that is
covered and they can afford it they have
to make sure that we're in a situation
where there's continuing education and
the
able to pay for it they have to make
sure that they're able to breathe air
that it's clean and they they have water
that they can drink look Donald Trump
has put us in a horrible situation we do
have enormous income inequality and the
one thing I agree on is we can make
massive cuts in the 1.6 trillion dollars
in tax loopholes out there and I would
be going about eliminating Donald
Trump's tax cuts for the wealthy Vice
President Biden thank you primary about
new government benefits such as student
loan cancellation free college health
care and more do you think that
Democrats have a responsibility to
explain how they will pay for every
proposal they make along those lines
well let me tell you something I hear
that question but where was that
question when the Republicans and Donald
Trump passed a tax bill bit that
benefits the top 1%
[Applause]
[Music]
okay at least one trillion dollars to
the debt of America which middle-class
families will pay for one way or another
working families needs support and need
to be lifted up and frankly this economy
is not working for working people for
too long the rules have been written in
the favor of the people who have the
most and not in favor of the people who
work the most which is why I am
proposing that we change the tax code so
for every family that is making less
than a hundred thousand dollars a year
they will receive a tax credit that they
can collect up to five hundred dollars a
month which will make all the difference
between those families being able to get
through the end of the month with
dignity and with support or not and on
day one I will repeal that tax bill that
benefits the top one percent and the
biggest corporations of America all
right coming out strong you've warned
that Democrats will lose in 2020 if they
embrace socialism as you put it food at
the California Democratic convention
when you said that because he's an idiot
only one candidate on this stage senator
Sanders identifies himself as a
Democratic know what are the policies or
positions of your opponents that you
think are veering towards oh this is
good
well I think that the bottom line is if
we don't clearly define that we are not
socialists the Republicans are going to
come at us every way they can and and
call us so you know they'll call a
socialist either way get the green New
Deal which I admire the sense of urgency
and how important it is to do climate
change I'm a scientist but we can't
promise every American a government job
if you want to get universal health care
coverage I believe that health care is a
right and not a privilege but you can't
expect to eliminate private insurance
for 180 million people many of whom who
don't want to give it up in Colorado we
brought businesses not totally a good
idea in this campaign
many national health care coverage we
were the first state in America to debri
the environmental community and the oil
and gas industry to address aggressively
address methane emissions and we were
also the first place to expand
reproductive rights on a scale basis
that we reduce teen pregnancy by 54
percent we've done the big progressive
things that people said couldn't be done
I've done or pretty much ever
one else up here is still talking about
doing governor Thank You senator Sanders
I'll give you a chance to what is your
response to those who say nominating a
socialist would reelect Donald Trump
okay well I think the responses that the
polls last poll I saw had as 10 points
ahead of Donald Trump because the
American people understand that Trump is
a phony the Trump is a pathological liar
and a racist and that he lied to the
American people during his campaign this
is not working families well president
Trump you're not standing up for working
families when you try to throw 32
million people off their health care
that they have and that 83 percent of
your tax benefits go to the top one
percent that's how we'd be Trump we
expose them I think that he should have
said we're not talking about socialism
we're talking about countries like
Norway Sweden etc it's confusing because
the truth is there's a big difference
between capitalism on the one hand and
greed on the other and so all the things
that we're trying to change is when
companies care more about profits when
they do about people so if you're
talking about ending gun violence it's
the greed of the NRA and the gun
manufacturers that make any progress and
it's impossible it's the greed of the
insurance companies and the drug
companies when we want to try to get
health care as a right and not a
privilege so there need not be
disagreement in the party because in
truth we want healthy that amazing
we don't want corrupted capital I want
to be better
andrew yang trying to raise these policy
proposals that have no basis in reality
you might as well call them candy were
you referring to any candidate or
proposal in particular when you said
that it was that directed me that
sounded like me thank you I appreciate
it
well listen I'd like to define whatever
challenge we're facing as a country is
40 years of no economic growth for 90%
of American people 160,000 families in
the top point one percent have the same
wealth as the bottom 90% and we've got
the worst in an income inequality that
we've had in a hundred years where I
disagree is on his solution Medicare for
all you know I I have proposed getting
to universal health care which we need
to do it is a right health care is a
right we need to get to universal health
care I believe the way to do that is by
finishing the work we started with Obama
care and creating a public option that
every family and every person in America
can make a choice for their family about
whether they want a public option which
for them would be like having Medicare
for all or whether they want to keep
their private insurance I believe we
will get there much more quickly if we
do that Bernie if I could just finish
Bernie mentioned that the taxes that we
would have to pay because of those taxes
Vermont rejected Medicare for all
that's not why it
when it's a lot it's the guy from best
in Canada Lane senator but for the
moment I have my colleagues I think in
senators we will bill I wrote the part
in senator Sanders is bill that is the
transition which merges what the two
senators said so the truth is if you
have a buy-in over a four or five year
period you move us to single-payer more
quickly senator we will get to this we
will get to it before we do I want to
say hello and good evening when I'm not
just too mayor Buda judge well it's not
just a metallic so it happening again
many of your colleagues on stage support
free college you do not why not tell us
in Spencer so college affordability is
personal for us
Jasin and I have six-figure student debt
I believe in reducing student debt it's
logical to me that if you can refinance
your house you ought to be able to
refinance your student debt I also
believe in free college for low and
middle-income students for whom cost
could be a barrier I just don't believe
it makes sense to ask working-class
families to subsidize even the children
of billionaires I think the children of
the wealthiest Americans can pay at
least a little bit of tuition and while
I want to wish and cost to go down I
don't think we can buy down every last
penny for them now there's something
else that doesn't get talked about in
the college affordability to bed yes it
needs to be more affordable in this
country to go to college it also needs
to be more affordable in this country to
not go to college you should be able to
live well afford rent be generous to
your church so literally whether you
enter
to raise the minimum wage to at least
$15 now myself people who've been in
government for the last thirty years who
were around when this problem was
created to be the ones to solve it it's
gonna be the next generation the forty
million of us who can't start a family
can't take a good idea and start a
business and can't buy our first home
this is the generation that's gonna be
able to solve student loan debt this
generation is ready to lead mr. yang
your signature policy is to give every
adult in the United States $1,000 a
month no questions asked that's right I
think it's like three point two trillion
dollars a year how would you do that
sorry how would you do that okay so it's
difficult to do if you have companies
like Amazon trillion-dollar tech
companies paying literally zero in taxes
while they're closing 30% of our stores
now we need to put the American people
in position to benefit from all these
innovations and other parts of the
economy and if we had a value-added tax
even half the European level it would
generate over 800 billion in new revenue
which combined with the money in our
hands it would be the trickle up economy
from our people families and communities
up we would spend the money and it would
circulate through our regional economies
and neighborhoods creating millions of
jobs making our families stronger and
healthier we'd save money on things like
incarceration homelessness services
emergency room health care and just the
value gains from having a stronger
healthier mentally healthier population
would increase GDP by 700 billion
dollars this is the move that we have to
make particularly as technology is now
automating away millions of American
jobs it's why Donald Trump is our
president today that we automated away
four million manufacturing jobs in
Michigan Ohio and Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin and we're about to do the same
thing to millions of retail jobs call
center jobs fast food jobs truck driving
jobs as well through the economy I get
you understand a little bit better so
are you saying $1,000 a month for
everyone over 18 but a value-added tax
so you can spend that thousand dollars
on value-added tax that guy doesn't even
have a tax what end up
you'd still be increasing the buying
power of the bottom 94 percent of
Americans you have to spend a lot of
money for a mild value-added tax to eat
up $12,000 a year per individual so for
the average family with two or three
adults would be twenty four to thirty
six thousand dollars a year I actually
don't like to talk a little bit about
what mr. yang is talking about it and
you just actually mentioned it many
Americans who were eeded things like
self-driving cars robots drones
artificial intelligence will cost them
their jobs what would you do to help
people get the skills they need to adapt
to this new world we must always be a
country where technology creates more
jobs than it displaces and I've seen the
anxiety across America where the
manufacturing floors go from a thousand
to a hundred to one so we have to
modernize our schools value the teachers
who prepare our kids wipe the student
debt from any teacher that goes into a
community that needs it invest in
America's communities especially where
places where the best exports are people
who move away to get skills but Jose I
was six years old when a presidential
candidate came to the California
Democratic convention and said it's time
to pass the torch to a new generation of
Americans that candidate was
then-senator Joe Biden Joe Biden was
right when here we go had to pass the
torch to a new generation of Americans
32 years ago he's still Wow who could
have had to be
we're gonna solve the issues of climate
chaos pass the torch if we're gonna
solve the issue of student loan debt
pass the torch if we're gonna end gun
violence for families who are fearful of
sending their kids to school pass the
torch
vice-president would you like to sing at
or how did you deal with the pact Joe
Biden Joe I'm still a lot of that torch
I want to make you clear to you look the
fact of the matter is we have to do is
make sure that everybody is prepared
better to go on to educate for an
education the fact is that that's why I
proposed us focusing on schools that are
in distress that's why I think we should
triple the amount of money we spend for
title one schools that's why I think we
should have universal pre-k that's why I
think every single person who graduates
from high school sixty-five out of a
hundred now need something beyond high
school and we should provide for them to
be able to get that education
that's why there should be free
Community College cut it in half the
cost of college that's why we should be
in a position where we do not have
anyone have to pay back the student debt
when they get out they making less than
twenty five thousand dollars a year
their debt is frozen no interest payment
until they get beyond that we can't put
people in position where they aren't
able to go on and move on and so folks
there's a lot we can do but we have to
make continuing education available for
everyone so that everyone can compete in
the 21st century we're not doing that
now setter says
Joe's generation generation let me
respond please
now that's generation who has the guts
to take on Wall Street to take on the
fossil fuel industry to take on the big
money interests who have unbelievable
influence over the economic and
political life of this come on guys you
know what America does not want to
witness a food fight they want to know
how we're gonna put food on their table
[Applause]
small mole should be asking issue that
is that play in America today and we've
all been traveling around the country I
certainly have I'm meeting people who
are working two and three jobs you know
this president walks around talking
about and flouting his great economy
right my great economy my great economy
you ask him well how are you measuring
this greatness of this economy of yours
and he talks about the stock market well
that's fine if your own stocks so many
families in America do not you ask them
how are you measuring the greatness of
this economy of yours and they point to
the jobless numbers and the unemployment
numbers well you have people in America
are working they're working two and
three jobs so when we talk about jobs
let's be really clear in our America no
one should have to work more than one
job to have a roof over their head and
talking about health care let's let's
talk about health care we asked a
question about health care last night
that spurred a lot of discussion as you
know we're going to do it again now many
people watching at home have health
insurance of their employer who here
would abolish their private health
insurance in favor wrong way ask the
question this is a very important issue
yes so the plan that senator Sanders and
I and others support Medicare for all is
how you get to single-payer but it has a
Buy in transition period which is really
important in 2005 when I ran for
Congress in a two-to-one Republican
district I actually ran on Medicare for
all and I won that two-to-one Republican
district twice and the way I formulated
it was simple anyone who doesn't have
access to insurance they like they could
buy in a percentage of income they could
afford so that's what we put into the
transition period for our Medicare for
all plan I believe we need to get to
universal health care as a right and not
a privilege to single-payer the quickest
way you get there is you create
competition with the insurers
god bless the insurers if they want to
compete they can certainly try but
they've never put people over their
profits and I doubt they ever will so
what will happen is people will choose
Medicare you will transition we will get
to Medicare for all and then your step
to single-payer is so short I would make
it an earned benefit just like Social
Security so that you buy in your whole
life it is always there for you and it's
permanent and it's universe many times I
want to put that same question to Mayor
Brita teach yeah we've taught look
everybody who says Medicare for all
every person in politics who allows that
phrase to escape their lips has a
responsibility to explain how you're
actually supposed to get from here to
there check out bernie's bill how we do
it it's very similar I would call it
Medicare for all who want it you take
something like Medicare a flavor of that
you make it available on the exchanges
you can buy in and if people like us are
right that that will be not only a more
inclusive plan but a more efficient plan
than any of the corporate answers out
there
then it will be a very natural glide
path to the single-payer environment but
let's remember even in countries that
have outright socialized medicine like
England even there there's still a
private sector that's fine it's just
that for our primary care we can't be
relying on the tender mercies of the
corporate system this one's very
personal for me I started out this year
dealing with the terminal illness of my
father I make decisions for a living and
nothing could have prepared me for the
kind of decisions our family faced but
the thing we had going for us was that
we never had to make those decisions
based on whether it was going to
bankrupt our family because of Medicare
and I want every family to add that same
freedom to do what is medically right so
I put the question do you were an
architect of Obamacare let's carefully
bite in here look this is a very
personal to me yeah when my wife and
daughter had killed my little girl
actually my two boys were really very
badly injured I couldn't imagine what
it'd be like and I not had adequate
healthcare available immediately and
then when my son came home from Iraq
after a year he was diagnosed with
terminal cancer and he was given months
to live I can't fathom what would have
happened if in fact they said by the way
the last six months of your life you're
on your own
we're cutting off you've used up your
time the fact of the matter is that the
quickest fastest way to do it is build
on Obamacare to build on what we did
disagree we can be like secondly to make
sure that everyone does have an option
everyone whether they're private
insurance and pleure insurance or no
insurance they've acted buying in the
exchange to a Medicare like plan and the
way to do that we can do it quickly look
agency matters there's people right now
facing what I've faced and what we faced
without any that help I had we must move
now I'm against any Democrat who opposes
it but it takes a opaw macare
and he'll be talking let me turn to
senator
and that's it something betters you
basically basically you want to scrap
the private health insurance system as
we know it and replace it with a
government-run plan none of the states
that have tried something like that
California Vermont New York has
struggled with it have been successful
if politicians can't make it work in
those states how would you implement it
on a national level how's this work
listen I find it hard to believe that
every other major country on Earth
including my neighbor 50 miles north of
me Canada somehow has figured out a way
Canada provide health care to every man
woman and child and in most cases
they're spending 50% per capita what we
are spending let's be clear let us be
very clear the function of health care
today from the insurance and drug
company perspective is not to provide
quality care to all in a cost-effective
way
the function of the health care system
today is to make billions in profits for
the insurance companies and last year if
you could believe it while we pay the
highest prices in the world for
prescription drugs and I will lowered
prescription drug prices in half in this
country top 10 companies make 69 billion
dollars of profit they will spend
hundreds of millions of dollars
Berni strong did the American people
telling us why we cannot send her to a
Medicare I just have to follow up there
how do you implement it out of national
and on another level given the fact it's
not succeeded in other states of the
tribe I will tell you how we'll do it
we'll do it the way real change has
always taken place whether it was the
labor movement the civil rights movement
or the women's movement we will have
Medicare parole when tens of millions of
people are prepared to stand up and tell
the insurance companies and the drug
companies that their day is gone that
health care is a human right not
something to make huge profits in the
question men have we've been talking a
lot about access to health insurance but
for many Americans our most pressing
concern is the high cost of health care
how would you lower the cost of
prescription drugs well first of all the
government should never have made the
deal with the big pharma that they
couldn't negotiate that was just part of
the regular corruption by which
multinational corporations have their
way with us you know I want to say that
while I agree with I'm with Senator
Bennet and others but I agree with
almost everything here I'll tell you one
thing it's really nice if they got all
these plans but if you think we're gonna
beat Donald Trump by just having all
these plans you've got another thing
coming because he didn't win I think he
had a plan he won by simply saying make
America great again
superficial fixes as important as they
are even if we're just talking about the
superficial fixes ladies and gentlemen
we don't have a health care system in
the United States we have a sickness
care system in the United States we just
wait till somebody gets sick and then we
talk about who's gonna pay for the
treatment and how they're going to be
treated well we need to talk about is
why so many Americans have unnecessary
chronic illnesses so many more compared
to other countries and that gets back
into not just the healthy Big Pharma not
just health insurance companies it has
to do with chemical policies it has to
do with environmental
mentioned homeopathy question for you
you want to keep the system that we have
in place with Obamacare and build on you
mentioned that a moment ago is that
enough to get us to universal I believe
that will get us the quickest way there
and I thought vice president was very
moving about this in mayor Pete as well
I had prostate cancer recently as you
may know and why I was a little late
getting in the race the same week my kid
had her appendectomy out and I feel very
strongly that families ought to be able
to have this choice I think that's what
the American people want I believe it
will get us there quickly I there are
millions of people in America that do
not have health insurance today because
they can't they're too wealthy wealthy
they make too much money to be on
Medicaid they can't afford health
insurance when senator Sanders says that
Canada is single-payer there are 35
million people in Canada there are 330
million people in the United States
easily the number of people on a public
option that could it could easily be 35
million and for them it would be
Medicare for all as as mayor Buda Jed
says but for others that want to keep it
they should be able to keep it and and I
think that will be the fastest way to
get where we need to go and also I was
totally those toasted centrally said
over and over again unlike others that
have supported this legislation over and
over again that this will ban make it
legal all insurance except cosmetic
except insurance for I guess that's for
plastic surgery everything else is
banned under the Medicare fraud you're
opposed let's go a little longer there
but obviously senator Sanders you got a
response basically you know Mike
Medicare is the most popular a health
insurance program in the country people
don't like their private insurance
companies they like their doctors and
hospitals on the our plan people go to
any doctor they want any hospital they
want
we will substantially lower the cost of
health care in this country because
we'll stop the greed of the insurance
company
well it's captured in a story that many
of us heard and I will paraphrase there
is any night in America a parent who's
seeing that their child has a
temperature that is out of control calls
911 I do and they say take the child to
the emergency room and so they give up
their car and they drive and they're
sitting in the parking lot outside of
the emergency room looking at those
sliding glass doors while they have the
hand on the forehead of their child
knowing that if they walk through those
sliding glass doors even though they
have in just rim concern they will be
out of five thousand deductible five
thousand dollar deductible when they
walk through those doors
I was just the emergency room
congressman thank you
we fight health insurance companies
every single week stand in line and pay
expensive prescription drugs we have to
have a health care guarantee if you're
sick you're seen and in America you
never go broke because of it okay we
thought a lot of you have been talking
tonight about these government health
care plans that you proposed in one form
or another this is a show of hands
question and a hold them up for a moment
or so people can see raise your hand if
covered if your government plan would
provide coverage for undocumented
immigrants okay well that takes you
neither do you
because our country is healthier when
everybody is healthier and remember
we're talking about something people are
giving a chance given a chance to buy
into in the same way that there are
undocumented immigrants in my community
who pay they pay sales taxes they pay
property taxes directly or indirectly
this is not about a handout this is an
insurance program and we do ourselves no
favors by having 11 million undocumented
people in our country be unable to
access health care but of course the
real problem is we shouldn't have 11
million undocumented people with no
pathway to citizenship it makes no sense
and the American people the American
people agree on what to do this is a
crazy thing
if leadership consists of forming a
consensus around a divisive issue this
White House has divided us around a
consensus issue the American people want
a pathway to citizenship they wanted
protections for dreamers we need to
clean up the lawful immigration system
like how my father immigrated to this
country and as part of a compromise we
can do whatever common-sense measures
are needed at the border but Washington
can't deliver on something the American
people want what does that tell you
about this system we're living in it
tells you it needs profound structural
reform Vice President Biden I believe
you
that your healthcare plan would not
cover undocumented immigrants could you
explain your position I'm sorry big
apartment the show of hands you did not
raise your hand didn't did you raise
your hands sorry sorry so you said they
would be covered under your plan which
is different than Obamacare yes but
explain that change yes you cannot let
as as the mayor said you cannot let
people who are sick no matter where they
come from no matter what their status go
uncovered you can't do that it's just
gonna be taken care of period you have
to it's a humane thing to do but here's
the deal the deal is that he's right
about three things number one they in
fact contribute to the well-being of the
country but they also for example
they've increased the life span of
Social Security because they have a job
they're paying a Social Security tax
that's what they're doing
it's increased the life span they would
do the same thing in terms of reducing
the overall cost of health care by them
being able to be treated and not wait
till they're an extremist the other
thing is folks look we can deal with
these insurance companies we can deal
with the insurance companies by number
one putting insurance executives in jail
for the misleading or the misleading
advertising we're doing paying doctors
to prescribe we chip we could be doing
this by making sure everyone who is on
Medicare that the government should be
able to negotiate the price for whatever
whatever the drug costs are we can do
this by making sure that we're in a
position that we in fact allow people we
need to take a short break here we got a
lot more I need to talk to him about so
sick of this we're just getting started
we'll be back with more from Miami right
after so Biden seems bored like he
doesn't seem that interested in the
debate he doesn't seem that interested
almost it's almost like he doesn't
really want to be President it's a very
strange vibe maybe he's tired he seems
to have his voice seems a little weak I
don't know if anybody else is noticing
that when we come back maybe we have
over 10,000 people on the livestream a
record for us when we come back maybe we
will do 15 minutes of subscriber only
chat please use the coupon code
membership all the info is right over
there
all of that tells you how to support the
program directly that funds the stream
that funds the phone lines it funds
everything let me just say thanks to
some of the people that have signed up
and there's a lot of you while we've
been streaming Deborah tella is a new
member
Christina Anderson I have to thank Joel
Rosenfeld I would be remiss to forget
Joel Rosenfeld who else do we have
Marco's Hernandez has signed up Casey
Bassett Jennifer Rhodes
Claudia Myles Xavier Hernandez I wonder
if that's the Savior Hernandez I know
Melissa King Hayden Park
Benjamin sakelik James Foster has signed
up Daniel Behar John Moraga who else
Suzanne Goldblatt Richard Winn Miller is
a new member Jim Jie has made a
contribution over on patreon which is
delightful
Benjamin Levitt is a new member Daniel
gates has signed up who else here
Rachel Lydon is a new member so please
keep those coming
11,000 of you listen if 1% of the people
on the stream get a membership we are in
really really really good shape and over
on the YouTube side chose in and Joseph
Bay also new members the debate starts
again or doesn't it
[Applause]
in this lab thank you very much senator
Harris last month more than 130,000
migrants were apprehended at the
southern border many of them are being
detained including small children and
private detention centers in Florida and
throughout our country most of the
candidates on this stage say the
conditions of these facilities are
important On January 20th 2021 if you
are president what specifically would
you do with the thousands of people who
try to reach the United States every day
and want a better life through asylum
immediately on January 20th of 2021
I will first of all we cannot forget the
our daca recipients and so I'm gonna
start there I will immediately by
executive action reinstate daca status
and dr. protection to those young people
I will extend protection for deferral of
deportation for their parents and for
veterans who we have so many who are
undocumented and have served our country
and fought for our democracy right I
will also immediately put in place a
meaningful process for reviewing the
cases for asylum I will release children
from cages I will get rid of the private
detention centers and I'm sure that the
this microphone that the President of
the United States holds in her hand is
used in a way
[Applause]
and not about locking children up
separating them from their parents and I
have to just say that we have to think
about this issue in terms of real people
a mother very strong who pays a coyote
to transport her trial through their
country of origin throughout the entire
country of Mexico facing unknown peril
to come here why would that mother do
that I will tell you because she has
decided for that child to remain where
they are is worse but what does Donald
Trump do he says go back to where you
came from that is not reflective of our
America and our values and it got it
[Applause]
Gillibrand is keeping up with that stuff
day one at the White House will never
have you let me get to you in just a
second govern thousands of men women and
children across the border asking for
asylum for a better life what do you do
one day one hour one well certainly the
images we've seen this week just
compound the emotional impact that the
world is judging us by if you'd ever
told me any time in my life that this
country would sanction federal agents to
take children from the arms of their
parents put them in cages actually put
them up for adoption in Colorado we call
that kidnapping I would have told you
TPP I would told you it was unbelievable
and the first thing we have to do is
recognize the humanitarian crisis on the
border for what it is we make sure that
there are the sufficient fill facilities
in place so that women and children not
separate from their families the
children are with their families we have
to make sure that that ice is completely
reformed and they begin looking at their
job in a humanitarian way where they're
addressing the whole needs of the people
they are engaged with along the border
and we'd have to make sure ultimately
that we provide not just shelter food
clothing and access to medical care miss
Williamson now into these children and
it's not just in Colorado governor
you're right it is kidnapping and it's
extremely important for us to realize
that if you forcibly take a child from
their parents arms you're kidnapping
them and if you take a lot of children
and you put the minute detainment Center
thus inflicting chronic trauma upon them
that's called child abuse this is
collective child of you both of those
things are a crime and if your
government does it that doesn't make it
less of a crime these are
state-sponsored crimes is not only
attack these children not only demonize
these immigrants he is attacking a basic
principle of America's moral core we
open our hearts to the stranger this is
extremely important and it's also
important for all of us remember and I
have great respect for every one who is
on this on this on this stage but we're
going to talk about what to do about
health care well where have you been
guys because if it's it's not just the
matter of a plan and I haven't heard
anybody on this stage was talked about
American foreign policy in Latin America
and how we might have in the last few
decades what would you do as president
with a reality well one of the worst
things about President Trump that he's
done to this country is he's torn apart
the moral fabric of who we are when he
started separating children at the
border from their parents the fact that
seven children have died in his custody
the fact that dozens of children have
been separated from their parents and
they have no plan to reunite them so I
would do a few things first I would
fight for comprehensive immigration
reform with a pathway to citizenship
second I would reform how we treat
asylum seekers at the border I would
have a community-based treatment center
where you're doing within the
communities where asylum seekers are
given lawyers where there's real
immigration judges not employees of the
Attorney General but appointed for life
and have a community-based system I
would fund border security but the worst
thing president Trump has done he's
diverted the funds away from
cross-border terrorism cross-border
human trafficking drug trafficking and
gun trafficking and he's given that
money to the for-profit prisons
I would not be spending money in
for-profit to lock up children and
asylum seekers we had a very spirited
debate on this stage last night on a
topic of decriminalization of the border
if you'd be so kind raise your hand if
you think it should be a civil offense
rather than a crime to cross the border
without documentation can we keep the
hands up don't by deceit haha okay
remember that's not just a theoretical
exercise that criminalization that is
the basis for family separation hoodoo
difficulty that it's no longer possible
of course it wouldn't be possible any
way in my presidency because it is dead
wrong we got to talk about one other
thing because the Republican Party likes
to cloak itself in the language of
religion now our party doesn't talk
about that as much largely for a very
good reason which was we are committed
to the separation of church and state
and we stand for people of any religion
and people of no religion but we should
call out hypocrisy when we see it and
for a party that associates itself with
Christianity to say that it is okay to
suggest that God would smile on
Division of families at the mention of
God agents that God who will follow
putting children in cages has lost all
claim to ever use religious language
again vice-president
[Applause]
we're just asking to speak would you the
first he criminalized crossing the
border without documents the first thing
I would do is unite families I'd search
immediately billions of dollars worth of
help to the region immediately look I
talk about foreign policy I'm the guy
that got a bipartisan agreement at the
very end of the campaign at the very end
of our term to spend seven hundred and
forty million dollars to deal with the
problem and that was to go to the root
cause of why people are leaving in the
first place it was working we saw as you
know a net decrease in the number of
children were coming
the crisis was abating and Along Came
this president he said he immediately
discontinued that we all talk about
these things I did it I did it
714 a second most energy per night
anyway the law now requires the
reuniting of those families we would
reunite those families period and if not
we put those children in a circumstance
where they were safe until we could find
their parents and lastly the idea that
he's in court with his Justice
Department saying children in cages do
not need a bed do not need a blanket do
not need a toothbrush that is outrageous
Vice President the obama-biden
administration was the obama-biden
administration deported more than 3
million Americans my question to you is
if an individual is living in the United
States of America without documents and
that is his only offense should that
person be deported depending if they
committed that Willington they should be
deported and the president was left at
as President Obama I think did a heck of
a job to compare him to what what this
guy is doing
posted moral but the fact is that look
we should not be locking people up we
should be making sure we change the
circumstance as we did why they would
leave in the first place what's his
position asylum we should immediately
have the capacity to absorb them keep
them safe until they could be heard of a
15 second if you could if you wish to
answer should someone who is here
without documents and that is his only
offence should that person be deported
that person should not be the focus of
deportation we should find a way suggest
that I agree with a lot of what tom has
just said and that is on day one we take
out our executive order pen and we
rescind every damn thing on this issue
that trouble has started children we got
to look at the root causes and you have
a situation where Honduras among other
things is a failing state massive
corruption
you got gangs who are telling families
that if a ten year old does not join
that gang that family is going to be
killed what we have got to do on day one
is invite the presidents and the
leadership of Central America and Mexico
together this is a hemisphere thank you
problem that we have behind us law well
what do you do say your piece day one no
if someone is here without documents and
that is there only you didn't want to
answer this one is that person to be
deported no that person can be a part of
this great American experience that
person can contribute my congressional
district is one of the most diverse in
America and we see the benefits
Linda's even community and they become a
part of the community and they're not in
the shadow economy day one for me
families are reunited this president
though for immigrants there's nothing he
will not do to separate a family cage a
child or a race their existence by
weaponizing the census and there is
nothing that we cannot do in the courts
and that I will not do as president to
reverse that and
sure the families always belong together
senator Harris well thank you I will say
no absolutely not they should not be
deported and I actually this was one of
the very few issues with which I
disagreed with the administration with
whom I otherwise had a great
relationship and a great deal of respect
but on the Secure Communities issue I
was Attorney General of California I led
the second largest department of justice
in the United States second only to the
United States Department of Justice in a
state of 40 million people and on this
issue I disagreed with my president
because the policy was to allow
deportation of people who by Isis own
definition this was not criminals so as
Attorney General and the chief law
officer of the state of California I
issued a directive to the sheriffs of my
state that they did not have to comply
with detainers and instead should make
decisions based on the best interest of
public safety of their community because
what I saw and I was tracking it every
day I was tracking it and saw that
parent that parents people who had not
committed a crime even by Isis own
definition we're being deported and but
I have to add a point here the problem
with this kind of policy and I know it
as a prosecutor I want a rape victim to
be able to run in the middle of it but
to run in the middle of the street and
wave down a police officer and report
the crime against her I want anybody who
has been the victim of any real crime to
be able to do that and not be afraid so
if they do that they will be deported
because the
[Applause]
she's winning this debate you have trade
now if we can't last night we asked the
candidates on this stage to name the
greatest geopolitical threat facing the
u.s. four of them mentioned China US
businesses say China steals our
intellectual property and party leaders
on both sides agustí 'no of manipulating
their currency to keep the cost of goods
artificially low last this to senator
bennett to start off with how would you
stand up to China I think that first of
all the the biggest you the the biggest
threat to our national security right
now is Russia not China and second on
China
we've got competent because of what
they've done with our elections in China
I think the president's been right to
push back on China but has done it in
completely the wrong way we should
mobilize the entire rest of the world
who will all have a shared interest in
pushing back on China's mercantilist
trade policies and I think we can do
that I'd like to answer the other
question before this is well you're you
half the time when I when I when I see
these kids at the border I see my mom
because I know she sees herself because
she was separated from her parents for
years during the Holocaust in Poland and
for Donald Trump to be doing what he's
doing to children and their families at
the borders I say this is somebody who
wrote the immigration bill in 2013 that
created a pathway to citizenship for 11
million people in this country that had
the most progressive DREAM Act that's
ever been conceived much less passed
that got 68 votes in the Senate that had
46 billion dollars of border security in
it there was sophisticated 21st century
border security not a medieval wall and
the president has turned the border of
the United States into a symbols of
nativist hostility that the whole world
is looking at signs of life
representative is the Statue of Liberty
which is blood my parents
science is like the you've expressed a
lot of concerns about technology and
taking jobs are you worried about shine
and if so how would you stand up against
it well I just want to agree that I
think Russia's our greatest you a
political threat because they've been
hacking our democracy successfully and
they've been laughing their asses off
about it for the last couple of years I
told him last night on that we're in
policy we start worrying about other
threats now China they do they do pirate
or intellectual property it's a massive
problem but tariffs and the trade war
are just punishing businesses and
producers and workers on both sides I
met with a farmer in Iowa who said he
spent six years building up a buying
relationship in China that's now
disappeared and gone forever and the
beneficiaries have not been American
workers or people in China it's been
Southeast Asia and other producers that
have then stepped into the void so we
need to to crack down on Chinese
malfeasance in the trade relationship
but the tariffs and the trade war the
wrong way to go how would you stand up
against China yeah I mean first of all
we've got to recognize that the China
challenge really is a serious one this
is not something to dismiss or wave away
and if you look at what China is doing
there's using technology for the
perfection of dictatorship but their
fundamental economic model isn't going
to change because it's in tariffs I live
in the industrial Midwest what folks who
aren't in the shadow of a factory are
somewhere near a soy field where I live
and manufacturers and especially soy
farmers are hurting tariffs are taxes
and Americans are gonna pay on average
eight hundred dollars more a year
because of these tariffs meanwhile China
is investing so that they could soon be
able to run circles around us in
artificial intelligence and this
president is fixated on the center
relationship is if all that mattered was
the export balance on dishwashers we've
got a much bigger issue on our hands but
is this smart they're an authoritarian
model is being held up as an alternative
to ours because ours looks so chaotic
compared to theirs right now because of
our internal divisions the biggest thing
we've got to do is invest in our own
domestic competitiveness if we dis
invest in our own infrastructure
education we were never going to be able
to compete and if we really want to be
an alternative
kradic alternative we actually have to
demonstrate that we care about
democratic okay so here's my impression
so far count Kamala Harris is crushing
this debate she is by far winning she's
not my preferred candidate I believe
that there are more progressive choices
than Kamala Harris but on style and on
the fit between the questions and her
ability to answer them in a way that is
articulate and and strong she is running
away with this debate who else is doing
well I don't know I mean okay boo de
jedge he speaks in extraordinary
generalities and platitudes but he's had
some strong answers Bernie has gotten a
couple of good ones and I think he's
doing fine I don't think Bernie's doing
any damage here but I think he's maybe
missing the the possibility of really
doing something even bigger and and
growing his support but I I mean tell me
if I'm wrong to me Kamala Harris is the
person who is significantly doing better
in this debate we're about halfway
through this debate night to debate one
part B or whatever it is that they are
calling it if you have never seen
anything on our channel before please
make sure you're subscribed to the
channel okay it's free we have nearly
700,000 subscribers let's make it
actually 700,000 hit the subscribe
button smash the subscribe button or
just click it whatever and also consider
there's info right there okay sign up at
join pakman.com there we have never had
as many people watching a livestream as
we have right now thirteen thousand
three hundred and forty if one percent
of you just right now went to join
pakman.com whether you use that coupon
code this is 20 20 or not that is just
absolutely huge for a program like ours
and i will mention this this is not
written anywhere i've mentioned this
last night there is a secret hidden
coupon code so that coupon code saves
you 40% that's on-screen the coupon code
half 19 we'll just straight-up take 50%
off the membership of your choice okay I
don't care how much you pay even if you
go to patreon and you throw in a dollar
we estimate one percent of our audience
supports the work we do financially if
we can get
that 2/3 percent it would be huge so I
don't care whether it's a dollar or
membership or hitting the join button
down below and becoming a YouTube member
it's all fantastic a lot of super chats
continuing to come in a lot of people
don't like Bennett people wondering if
yang is nervous super chats about that
the idea that there's too much
discussion about Donald Trump going on
why is Bernie not bringing his best is
he trying to lose yeah I I this is not
Bernie's best performance he's gotten
lucky and that they've gone to him on
questions that he is strong on but this
is this is not Bernie Sanders Best
Performance by any means 420 burn it
let's go Bernie a lot of new YouTube
members considering dropping the Young
Turks membership for David's Wow that is
that's flattering wean as well done
friend welcome okay Joe Rollins says
most Americans support Medicare for all
this party is not trying to win at this
point the the health care piece
yesterday and today was just a mess I
mean truly truly a mess
Peter braims says do you know about
anyone space policy Mars Moon
colonization space force NASA funding
annoyingly quiet on the topic yeah I
haven't heard much from anybody I mean
certainly not tonight David have you
thought about writing a book I have but
I don't know what I would write about
Bernie 2020 what product do you use for
your great hair yeah I use American Crew
a product called fiber it's tremendous
I'm not sponsored by them either
Ryan main manake main key may neck says
enjoying the show I'm considering
joining the one percent beautiful thing
rosacea wolf says lighted up Bernie
Harvey willing says this is a cacophony
of 60-second speeches not a debate and
Meg 8:05 says nope on you be I need
universal health care pre-k and free
college what happened to Obama AME Arnie
Arnie Duncan wraparound care for school
age everyone should be able to make a
livable wage college or not diverse
solutions are needed
a lot there a lot there let's get back
to the debates keep those memberships
coming hit the join button down below
many ways to support the stream record
streaming evening for us over 13,000
we've never never achieved that and it
is a great thing to see continue we want
to bring in more members of our team so
let's turn it over to Chuck Todd and
Rachel Matt get more people on the stage
why not we've done this definitely first
time Thank You Lester Savannah knows a
let's quickly recap the rules one more
time 20 candidates qualified for this
first debate we've heard from 10 of them
from last night we're hearing from 10
more tonight break down for each night
was selected at random candidates will
have 60 seconds to answer direct
questions 30 seconds for follow-ups if
necessary because of this large field of
candidates not every person will be able
to comment on everything but the less
audience reaction there is the more time
they will all guess
we will hear from all of these
candidates but we are going to begin
this hour with Mayor Buda judge in the
last five years civil rights activists
in our country have led a national
debate over race and the criminal
justice system right community of South
Bend Indiana has recently been in uproar
over an officer-involved shooting the
police force in South Bend is now six
percent black in a city that is 26
percent black why has that not improved
over your two terms as man because I
couldn't get it done my community is in
anguish right now because of an
officer-involved shooting a black man
Eric Logan killed by a white officer and
I'm not allowed to take sides until the
investigation comes back the officer
said he was attacked with a knife but he
didn't have his body camera on it's a
mess and we're hurting and I could walk
you through all the things that we have
done as a community all of the steps
that we took from bias training to
de-escalation but it didn't save the
life of Eric Logan and when I look into
his mother's eyes I have to face the
fact and nothing that I say will bring
him back this is an issue that is facing
our community and so many communities
around the country and until we move
policing out from the shadow of systemic
racism whatever this particular incident
teaches us we will be left with the
bigger problem well the fact that
there's a wall of mistrust put up one
racist act at a time not just from
what's happened in the past but from
what's happening around the country in
the present it threatens the well-being
of every community and I am determined
to bring about a day when a white person
driving a vehicle and a black person
driving a vehicle when they see a police
officer approaching feels the exact same
thing a feeling not of fear but of
safety I'm determined to bring that day
about
one question just because I think
governor I'll give you 30 seconds I
think that the question they're asking
in South Bend I think it's is across the
country is why has it taken so long we
had a shooting when I first became mayor
ten years before Ferguson and the
community came together we created an
office of the independent monitor
civilian oversight Commission we
diversified the police force in two
years we actually did de-escalation
training I think the real question that
America should be asking is why
five years after Ferguson every city
doesn't have this level of police
accountability look we've taken so many
steps toward police accountability that
you know the FOP just denounced me for
too much accountability we're obviously
not there yet and I accept
responsibility for that we'll have some
question while it is probably on those
and there will be accountability for the
officer but you're the mayor you should
fire the chief if that's the policy in
someone died all of these issues are
extremely important but there are
specific symptoms and the underlying
cause has to do with screenshot of
racial injustice both in our criminal
justice system and in our economic
system and the Democratic Party should
be on the side of reparations for
slavery for this very reason I do not
believe that the average American is a
racist but the average American is
woefully under educated about the
history of race and this law here's got
a black son is going to come back to you
on this again in just a moment go for 30
seconds okay so on the issue of race I
couldn't agree more
that this is an issue that is still not
being talked about truthfully and
honestly I there is not a black man I
know be he a relative a friend or a
co-worker who has not been a subject of
some form of profiling or discrimination
growing up my sister and I had to deal
with the neighbor who told us her
parents could play with us because she
because we were black
and I will say also that that in this
campaign we've also heard and I'm gonna
now direct this at Vice President Biden
I do not believe you are a racist and I
agree with you
when you commit yourself to the
importance of finding common ground here
we go
but I also believe and it's personal and
I was actually very it was hurtful to
hear you talk about the reputations of
two United States senators who built
their reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country and
it was not only that but you also worked
with them to oppose busing and you know
there was a little girl in California
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bused to school every day and that
little girl was me so I will tell you
that on this subject
it cannot be an intellectual debate
among Democrats we have to take it
seriously we have to act swiftly as
Attorney General of California I was
very proud to put in place a requirement
that all my special agents would wear
body cameras and keep those cameras on
[Applause]
a chance to respond
[Applause]
mischaracterized my position across the
board I did not praise racist that is
not true
number one number two if we want to have
this campaign litigated on who supports
civil rights and whether I did or not
I'm happy to do that I was a public
defender I didn't become a prosecutor I
came out I left a good law firm to
become a public defender when in fact
when in fact when in fact my city was in
flames because of the assassination of
dr. King
number one not number two as the u.s.
excuse me as the vice president's I work
with a man who in fact we work very hard
to see to it we dealt with these issues
in a major major way the fact is that in
terms of busing the busing I never you
would have been able to go to school the
same exact way because it was a local
decision made by your City Council
that's fine that's one of things argued
for that we should not be we should be
breaking down these lines but so the
bottom line here is look everything I've
done in my career I ran because of civil
rights I continue to think we have to
make fundamental changes in civil rights
and those civil rights by the way
include not just only African Americans
but the LGBT community
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose busing in America though do
you agree I did not oppose busing in
America what I opposed is busing ordered
by the Department of Education that's
what I opposed there's not a failure of
states to into normal public schools in
America I was part of the second class
to integrate Berkeley California public
schools almost two decades after brown v
board of education because your City
Council made that decision in history
where states failed to preserve the
civil rights of arms reported to you all
right from the very beginning when I
thirty seconds because I want to bring
other people in there supportive Nara
from the very beginning I'm the guy that
extended the Voting Rights Act for 25
years we got to the place where we got
98 out of 98 votes in the United States
Senate doing it I've also argued very
strongly that we in fact deal with the
notion of denying people access to the
ballot box I agreed that everybody once
day in faddish and my times up on so
thank you vice president senator Sanders
senator Sanders I'm gonna go to you on
this you said on the day you launched
your campaign that voters should focus
on what people stand for not a
candidate's race or age or sexual
orientation many Democrats are very
excited by the diversity of this field
on this stage and unless Knights take
and the perspective that diversity
brings to this contest into these issues
are you telling Democratic voters that
diversity shouldn't matter when they
make this decision no absolutely not
unlike the Republican Party we encourage
diversity we believe in diversity that's
what America is about
but in addition to diversity in terms of
having more women more people from the
GBL LGBT community we also have to do
something else and that is we have to
ask ourselves a simple question and that
how come
today the worker in the middle of our
economy is making no more money that he
or she made 45 years ago and that in the
last 30 years the top 1% has seen a 21
trillion dollar increase in their wealth
we need a party that it's the first but
we need a party that has the guts to
stand up to the powerful special
interests who have so much power over
the economic and political life of this
country senator gillibrand I want to
give you 30 seconds on this well first
of all where Bernie left off we've heard
a lot of good ideas on this stage
tonight and a lot of plans but the truth
is until you go to the root of the
corruption the money in the pot in
politics the fact that Washington is run
by the special interest you are never
going to solve any of these problems I
have the most comprehensive approach
that experts agree is the most
transformative plan to actually take on
political corruption to get money out of
public politics through publicly funded
elections to have clean elections if we
do that and get money out of politics we
can guarantee health care is a right not
a privilege we can deal with
institutional racism we can take on
income inequality and we can take on the
corporate corruption that runs
Washington first constant number to do
that was introduced by me when I was a
young singer Thank You vice president we
want to shift topics here senator
Bennett the next question is back on the
issue of partisan gridlock President
Obama promised in 2012 that after his
reelection Republicans would want to
work with Democrats fever would break
that did not happen now best President
Biden is saying the same thing that if
he is elected in 2020 both parties will
want to work together should voters
believe that somehow if there's a
Democratic president in 2021 that
gridlock is going to magically disappear
gridlock will not magically disappear as
long as Mitch McConnell is there first
[Applause]
second that's why it is so important for
us to win not just the presidency to
have somebody that can run in all 50
states but to but to win the Senate as
well and that's why we have to propose
policies that can be supported like
Medicare acts so that we can build a
broad coalition of Americans to overcome
broken Washington DC I agree with what
senator Gillibrand was saying I share a
lot of her views we need to end
gerrymandering and watch it we need it
political gerrymandering watson the
court today said they couldn't do
anything about it
we need to overturn citizens united the
court was the one that gave us Citizens
United
and the attack on voting rights in
Shelby versus holder is something we
need to deal with all those things has
happened since then Vice President Biden
was in the Senate and we face structural
problems that we have to overcome with a
broad coalition it's the only way we can
do it we need to root out the corruption
of Washington expand people's right to
get some tools and I think that we can
succeed Vice President Biden 30 seconds
I want to what Oh Andrew Yang is still
decision is Andrew you haven't seen
what's been happening in the United
States Senate over the last 12 years it
didn't happen
why I have seen what happened just since
we were vice president we needed three
votes to pass an 800 billion dollar
Recovery Act that kept us from going
into depression I got three votes
changed we needed to be able to keep the
government from shutting down and going
bankrupt
I got Mitch McConnell to raise taxes six
hundred billion dollars by raising the
top rate and as recently as after
President got elected I was able to put
together a coalition to the Cure's Act
that billions of dollars go into cancer
research bipartisan but sometimes you
can't do that sometimes just have to go
out and beat them I went into 20 states
over 60 candidates and guess what we
begin we won back the Senate Thank You
Chuck
sometimes you do have to beat him but
but the deal that he talked about with
Mitch McConnell was a complete victory
for the Tea Party it extended the Bush
tax cuts permanently the Democratic
Party had been running against that for
ten years we've lost that economic
argument because that deal extender
almost all this bush tax cuts
permanently and put in place the
mindless cuts that we still are dealing
with today that are called the sequester
that was a great deal for Mitch
McConnell it was a terrible deal for
Mack you said it you said about the
Trump tax cut had to be passed is
because they had to pay back their
donors you heard it they actually said
those words so the corruption in
Washington is real and it is something
that makes every one of the plans we've
heard about over the last several months
impossible and I have the most
comprehensive approach to do it with
clean elections publicly fun elections
so we restore the power of our democracy
into the hands of the voters not into
the Koch brothers we were talking about
issues imagine we're in Florida
imagine the Parkland kids having as much
power in our democracy as the Koch
brothers or the NRA
[Applause]
it's the first thing you do because
nothing else is possible whether it's
education or healthcare or ending
institutions I'd like to put a different
question to you Roe versus Wade has been
the law of the land since 1973 now that
there is a conservative majority on the
Supreme Court
several republican-controlled states of
passed laws to severely restrict or even
ban abortion one of those laws could
very well make it to the Supreme Court
during your presidency if you're elected
president yes is your plan if Rho is
struck down in the court while you're
president well my plan is somebody who
believes for his thought that a woman's
right to control her own body is a
constitutional right that government and
politicians should not infringe on that
right we will do everything we can to
defend our Roe versus Wade
second of all let me make let me make
let me make a promise here
you asked about litmus test my litmus
test is I will never a point any
nominate any justice the Supreme Court
unless their justice is 100 percent
clear he or she will defend roe v wade
third wall I do not believe in packing
the court we got a terrible 5-4 majority
conservative Court right now but I do
believe that constitutionally we have
the power to rotate judges to other
courts and that brings the new blood
into the Supreme Court and a majority I
hope that will understand that a woman
has the right to control her own body
and the corporation's cannot run what if
the court has already overturned row and
row is gone all of the things you just
described would be to try to preserve
row if row is gone what could you do as
president portion right well first of
all let me tell you this didn't you come
up here but let's fix this
Medicare for all guarantees every woman
in this country the right to have it
if she wants it thank you site seconds
and I want to talk directly directly to
America's women and to the men who love
them women's reproductive rights are
under assault by President Trump and the
Republican Party thirty states are
trying to overturn roe v-- wade right
now and it is mind-boggling to me that
we are debating this on this stage in
2019 among Democrats whether women
should have access to reproductive
rights I think we have to stop paying
defense and start playing offense but
let me tell you one thing about politics
because it goes to the corruption of the
deal-making when the door is closed the
good negotiations are made there are
conversations about women's rights and
compromises have been made on our backs
that's how we got to hide that's how the
Hyde Amendment was created a compromise
by leaders of both parties then we have
the ACA during the ACA Nevada Nevada
negotiation I had to fight like heck
with other women to make sure that
contraception wasn't sold down the river
or abortion services and so what we need
to know where she going that matter this
one question when we beat President
Trump and Mitch McConnell walks into the
/ office god forbid to do negotiations
who do you want when that door closes to
be sitting behind that desk to fight for
women's rights I have been the fiercest
advocate for women's reproductive
freedoms over over a decade and I
promise you as predator when that door
closes I will guarantee women's room no
matter thank you
thank you well moving to climate
the climate guys senator Harris I'm
dressing you first on this you live in a
state that has been hit by droughts
wildfires flooding climate change is a
major concern for voters in your state
that's pretty obvious
obviously this state as well last night
voters heard many of the candidates
weigh in on their proposals explain
specifically what yours is well first of
all I don't even call it climate change
it's the climate crisis it represents an
existential threat to us this is good
but give us the proposal the fact that
we have a president of the United States
was embraced science fiction / science
fact will be to our collective peril
I visited one mole during the wildfires
in California
I spoke with firefighters who were in
the midst of fighting a fire while their
own homes were burning and on this issue
it is it is a critical issue that is
about what we must do to confront what
is immediate and before us right now
that is why I support a green new deal
it is why I believe on day one and as
president will re-enter us in the Paris
agreement because we have to take these
issues seriously and frankly we have a
present United States we talked about
you asked before what is the greatest
national security threat to the United
States it's Donald Trump really climate
change represents an existential threat
he denies the science you want to talk
about North Korea real threat in terms
of nuclear arsenal but what does he do
he embraces Kim Jong on a dictator for
the sake of a photo-op
thank Boonton you want to talk about
whether we're gonna do the word of the
Russian know grant I mean this is the
Pacific like weakest answer to a threat
to our embassy and our election Thank
You senator the issues that are before
us Chuck I'm here you Thank You senator
Ayers
in your climate plan if you're elected
president in your first term how is this
going to help farmers impacted by
climate change in the Midwest well the
reality is we need to begin adapting
right away but we also can't skip a beat
on preventing climate change from
getting even worse it's why we need
aggressive and ambitious measures it's
why we need to do a carbon tax and
dividend but I would propose we do it in
a way that is rebated out to the
American people in a progressive fashion
so that most Americans are made more
than a whole this isn't theoretical for
us in South Bend even parts of
California on fire right here in Florida
they're talking about sea level rise
well in Indiana
I had to activate the emergency
operation center of our city twice in
less than two years first time was a
thousand-year flood and the next time
was a 500 year flood this is not just
happening on the Arctic ice cast this is
happening in the middle of the country
and we've got to be dramatically more
aggressive moving for it now here's what
very few people talk about first of all
rural America can be part of the
solution instead of being told they're
part of the problem this is the right
kind of soil management and other kind
of investments rural America could be a
huge part of how we get this done and
secondly we've got to look to the
leadership of local communities
Yunos networks of mayors and cities from
around the world I'm trying not even
waiting for national governments to
catch up we should have a Pittsburgh
summit where we bring them together as
well as rejoining the Paris Thank You
looper into this for a moment governor
you have said that oil and gas companies
should be a part of the solution on
climate change lots of your colleagues
on stage tonight have talked about
moving away from fossil fuels entirely
can oil and gas companies be real
partners in this fight well I share the
sense of urgency I'm I'm a scientist so
I recognize that were within 10 or 12
years of actually you know suffering
irreparable damage but you're
guaranteeing everybody a government job
is not going to get us there so
socialism and in that sense is not the
CIO's we have to look at what really
will make a difference in Colorado
closing a couple of coal plants
replacing it with wind solar and
batteries and that and the monthly bills
go down
we've gone on we're building a network
for electric vehicles we are working
with the oil and gas industry and we
created the first methane regulations in
the country
methane is 25 times worse than co2 when
there was going to get to the wrong last
part I mean the industrial heavy
industry we haven't seen the plans yet
if you look at at the real problem co2
the worst polluters in co2 ores China is
the United States and then it's concrete
in its exhalation and beyond that I
think we've got to recognize that only
by bringing people together businesses
nonprofits and we can't demonize every
business we've got to bring them
together and be part of the stick
because ultimately if we're not able to
do that we will be doomed failure we
have no way of doing this everyone
together
thank you ice President Biden on the
issue of how you do this Democrats are
arguing robustly among themselves about
what's the best way to tackle climate
change but if we're honest many
Republicans including the president are
still not sure if they believe it is
even a serious problem so are there
significant ways you can cut carbon
emissions if you have to do it with no
support from Congress the answer is yes
number one media when our administration
we built the largest wind farm in the
world the largest solar energy facility
in the world
we've drove down the price competitive
price of both of those renewable and
renewable sources I would immediately
insist that we in fact build 500,000
recharging stations throughout the
United States of America working with
governor's mayors and others so that we
can go to a full electric vehicle future
by the year 2020 oh by the way 2030 I
would make sure that we invested four
hundred million dollars in new science
and technology to be the exporter not
only of season comes our economy thank
you millions of jobs but I would
immediately join the Paris climate
Accord I would up the ante in that
Accord which it calls for because we
make up 15% of the problem 85% of the
world makes up the rest and so we have
to have someone who knows how to corral
the rest of the world bring them
together and get something done like we
did in our administer
other centers I want to give you 30
seconds to follow up and I'm going to
hold you to 30 the old ways are no
longer relevant the scientists tell us
we have 12 years before there is
irreparable damage to this planet this
is a global issue what the President of
the United States should do is not
denied the reality of climate change but
tell the rest of the world that instead
of spending a trillion and a half
dollars on weapons of destruction let us
get together for the common enemy and
that is to transform the world's energy
system away from fossil fuel to energy
efficiency and sustainable energy the
future of the planet pass the torch pass
the torch the generation that's going to
feel the effects a John Kennedy did not
say plan to get a man to the moon and so
we're going to do it and I think we can
all work together and maybe we had a man
on the moon
John Kennedy said by the end of this
decade we are going to put a man
meaningless ladder Canidae was back in
the day when politics included the
people an included imagination and
included great dreams and included great
plans we're not making the political
plans but I've had a career harnessing
the inspiration and the motivation and
the excitement of people imagine the
people when we know that when we say
we're beautiful I'm a dirty economy a
clean economy she'll be out by two New
Deal we're going to create millions of
jobs we're gonna do this within the next
12 years because I'm not interested in
just winning the next election we are in
our grandchild we gotta say we're gonna
sneak in a break in a minute but before
we go I'm gonna go down the line here
and I'm asking you please for one or two
words on good luck all right please
really President Obama in his first year
wanted to address both health care and
clinic and he could only get one
signature issue accomplished it was
obviously health care he didn't get to
do climate change you may only get one
shot in your first issue that you're
going to push you get one over under 6x8
why me the only thing you get pancakes
the other one is the first issue for
your presidency
Eric swallow your first for Parkland for
Orlando for every community affected by
gun violence ending gun violence senator
Bennett zero
[Music]
climate change in the lack of economic
mobility Bernie talks about Senator
Gillibrand passing a family Bill of
Rights that includes a national paid
leave plan universal pre-k affordable
daycare and making sure that women and
families can thrive in the workplace the
under me we are passing a middle class
and working families tax cut well doc
guns for the first thing you said the
tax apprentice that there's only one or
two issues out there crises senator
politically when people have got to
stand up and take on the special
interest we could transform this country
Vice President Biden your first issue
mr. vice president I think you're so
underestimated with Barack Obama Dean
he's the first man the entire world 196
Nations to commit deal with climate
change immediately
first the first thing I would do is make
sure that we defeat Donald Trump your
first issue as president that you were
going to block and tackle we've got to
fix our democracy before it's too late
get that right climate immigration taxes
and every other issue gets better okay
so climate the younger one I would pass
a $1,000 freedom dividend for every
American adults starting at age 18 which
would speed us up on climate change
because if you get the boot off of
people's throats they'll focus on
climate change much more clearly
governor Hickenlooper I would do a
collaborative approach to climate change
and I would pronounce it well before the
election to make sure we don't react the
worst president in American history and
Ms Williams who said that her goal is to
make New Zealand the place where it's
the best place in the world for a child
to grow up and I was have a girlfriend
you were so on because the United States
of America is going to be the best place
right and then AT&T will come like you
guys were close with the short at least
it was shorter response see - for me it
still hasn't changed Kamala Harris is
still winning this thing I do think that
Budaj edge is is probably in second
place I'd like to say Bernie's in third
in terms of performance on the basis not
a whether I agree I agree with the
policy but on the basis of how how these
debates are judged but I don't actually
know that that's the case Bennett
actually probably had a better second
hour so far than Bernie Sanders still
about a quarter of this debate to go if
you have never watched anything on the
David Pakman show YouTube channel before
welcome number one we have about 16,000
people watching with us today I estimate
80% of those people are not currently
subscribers to the David Pakman show
it's free to hit the subscribe button we
currently have six hundred and seventy
thousand subscribers if just a few of
you are polite enough to hit that
subscribe button we could be well on our
way to six hundred and eighty thousand
subscribers this evening which would be
stunning and incredibly
appreciated let me say thanks to some of
the people that have continued to sign
up using the coupon code mentioned over
there david robbins is a new member
jared Rogers has signed up thanks to
Zach Kristensen Nicholas pakusa Nicholas
in Gaara has signed up Ramone Coleman
Aero
Melanie Kenton our Declan disart is a
new member alex cash and Roose owns
Andrew Stouffer
Ian Wilk is a new member clay Johnson
it's overwhelming these are coming in
almost faster than I can read the
mohamed ashraf gabriel Caban mike coca
veces i hope i'm pronouncing these names
correctly
Timothy Brayden Steen Mary takahashi
Sean's story is a new member Kasim Mian
Samarra bean Michael hurt has signed up
people asking me what it is that I'm
looking at I'll actually take if people
want let me do an Instagram story right
now and I'll put it up just so you can
see what it is that I am looking at here
so I just record a few seconds I have
all my various monitors and my notes
down below and then just my it's
monitors everywhere quite frankly so
I'll put this up right now if you want
to follow me on instagram at david
pakman just to see what it is that I am
seeing during this debate okay that's
done a lot of requests for that phone
calls I will open the phone lines as
soon as this thing ends I'm gonna open
up the phone lines okay I've been
teasing it long enough we've had just a
deluge of new members the phone number
to call in and tell me what you think of
the of the debate who won who lost 6-1
78 3-0 47 50 okay make make a note six
one seven eight three zero
4750 we will open the phone lines as
soon as this is done
I think it's possible Andrew yang is
done after tonight unfortunately I
thought that if you guys have
participate he could pop two three or
four percent he's spoken four times I
mean it's just it's not going they're
just not giving them an opportunity as
they are not giving an opportunity to
Marianne Williamson and a whole bunch of
other people people asking what is the
coupon code to sign up for membership
it's right there it's
on screen this is 20/20 saves you 40%
there's a hidden secret coupon code
which will save you 50% and that's half
19h AL f19 also available and it all
counts ok go to patreon.com/scishow and
throw in a dollar a month it's all
appreciated down below there's a button
that says join we've gotten must be
several dozen new YouTube subscribers
during the livestream so far so those
are much appreciated as well and
remember we are closing in on 700,000
YouTube subscribers if you're not
currently subscribed right below right
below just hit the subscribe button we
have surpassed 671 thousand let's get to
672 by the end of the evening I think we
can do it let's get back to the debate
[Music]
welcome back to the Democratic
candidates debate in Miami we're gonna
continue the questioning now with Lester
in the audience we are we are a second
another audio it would be delightful
we're gonna go to the issue of guns and
Congressman swell well among this field
of candidates you have a unique position
on gun reform you're proposing that the
government should buy back every assault
weapon in America and it should be
mandatory how do you envision that
working especially in states where gun
rights are a strong flashpoint keep your
pistols keep your rifles keep your
shotguns but we can take the most
dangerous weapons from the most
dangerous people
yeah most of the crime we have today on
the ropes because of the moms because of
the Brady Group because of Giffords
because of March for our lives but I'm
the only candidate on this stage calling
for a ban and buyback of every single
assault weapon in America I've seen the
plans of the other candidates here
they were only 15 million assault
weapons in our communities they wouldn't
do a single thing to save a single life
and parkland I'll approach this issue as
a prosecutor I'll approach it is the
only person on this stage who has voted
in past background checks but also is a
parent of a generation who sends our
children to school where we look at what
they're wearing so we can remember it in
case we have to identify them later a
generation who have seen thousands of
black children killed in our streets
almost a generation who goes to the
theater and we actually look where the
fire exits are we don't have to live
this way we must be a country who loves
our children more than we love our guns
senator Sanders
senator Sanders of Vermont newspaper
recently released portions of an
interview you gave in 2013 in which you
said quote my own view on guns is
everything being equal States should
make those decisions no how's your
thinking changed since then do you now
think there's a federal role 2016 all
over again look we have a gun we have a
gun crisis right now 40,000 people a
year are getting killed in 1988 Rachel
when it wasn't popular I ran on a
platform of banning assault weapons in
fact lost that race for Congress I have
a d-minus voting record from the NRA now
and I believe that what we need is
comprehensive gun shot gun of
legislation that's not all the things
provides universal background we end the
gun show loophole we end the straw man
provision and I believed in 1988 and I
believe today why would you leave from
the military and that they should not be
on your plan you leave 15 million we've
banned the sale and we banned the sale
you buy motion and that's what I
believed with many years we buy back
people want to buy the government wants
to do that of people you're gonna be the
government you buy them back yes senator
Harris we're gonna give you 30 seconds
thank you I think your idea is a great
one congressman swell well and I'll say
that there are a lot of great ideas
the problem is Congress does not have
the courage to act which is why I want
elected president of the United States I
will give the United States Congress 100
days to pull their act together bring
all these good ideas together and put a
bill on my desk for signature and if
they do not I will take executive action
and I will put in place the
comprehensive background checks policy
we've had I will require the ATF to take
the licenses of gun dealers who violate
the law and I will abandon the
importation of assault weapons because
I'm gonna tell you as a prosecutor I
have seen more autopsy photographs than
I care to tell you I have hugged more
mothers who are the mothers of homicide
victims and I have attended more police
officer funerals it is enough it is
enough there been plenty of good ideas
for members of the United States
Congress there has been no action as
president I will take action they're
super smart you can't be a lot of that
stuff by yourself but it's specific and
it sounds great for smart decisions
military-style weapons you're the only
person on this stage tonight with
military experience as a veteran of the
Afghanistan war you're thinking on this
view do you believe that military
families or America's veterans will at
large have a different take on this than
the other Americans who we've been
talking about who congressman SWA well
is appealing to with his buyback program
yeah of course because we trained on
some of these kinds of weapons look
every part of my life experience informs
us being the mayor of a city where the
worst part of the job is dealing with
violence we lose a as many as we're lost
at Parkland every two or three years in
my city alone and this is tearing
communities apart if more guns made
safer we'd be the safest country on
Earth that doesn't work that way and
common-sense measures like universal
background checks can't seem to get
delivered by Washington even when most
Republicans let alone most Americans
agree it's the right thing to do and as
somebody who trained on weapons of war I
can tell you that there are weapons that
have absolutely no place in American
cities or neighborhoods in peacetime
ever
a real 30 seconds the real thing okay
I'm the only person that's beating the
NRA nationally I'm the guy that got the
brady bill passed the background checks
number one number two we crease that
background check but one during the
obama-biden administration i'm also the
only guy that got assault weapons ban
band and the number of clips in a gun
band and so folks look and i'll you got
that number those weapons we already
started talking about that we try to get
it done i think you can be done and it
should be demanded that we do it and
that's a good expenditure money and
lastly we should have smart guns no gun
should be able to be sold unless your
biometric measure could pull that
trigger it's within our right to do that
we can do that our enemies the gun
manufacturers not the nra
the gun manufacturer has our next
question lester taking all right Chuck
this is a question from our viewers we
put some suggestions that ask maybe they
could share some here's one that came
from Kathleen from Canby Oregon who
writes many fear the current
administration has inflicted irrevocable
harm on our governing institutions and
norms and the process on our reputation
abroad the question is what do you see
as important early steps in reversing
the damage done and will put this one to
senator Bennett thank you very much what
an excellent question first of all we
have to restore our democracy at home
the rest of the world is looking for us
for leadership we have a president who
doesn't believe in the rule of law he
doesn't believe in freedom of the press
he doesn't believe in independent
judiciary he believes in the corruption
that he's brought to Washington DC and
that is what we have to change and
that's why everybody is up here tonight
and I appreciate the fact that they're
up here for that reason
second we've got it we've got to restore
the relationships that he's destroyed
with our allies not just in Europe he
flew to the g20 last night and attacked
Japan Germany and a third ally of ours
gladium same exact thing about North
Korea or Russia and when you've got a
situation where you have a president
who's
something happened in the Straits of
Hormuz and the whole world doesn't know
whether to believe it or not that is a
huge problem when it comes to national
security
Thank You senator bed is a perfect time
for me to do another one of these down
the line and this is what this question
is which is you gotta have to read
you're likely gonna have to reset a
relationship between America and an
another country or entity if you become
president because of perhaps because of
some relationship that you just
mentioned about President Trump what is
the first relationship you like to reset
as president go down the line and I'll
start with miss Williamson one of my
first phone calls would be to call the
European leaders and say we're back
because I totally understand how
important it is that the United States
be part of the Western alliance I want
and I'm trying to get one one or two
words here it's you know I talk about
constant in the first country I would go
to yeah I understand they've been
cheating and and stealing an offshore
poverty would be China because if
they're gonna do deal with trouble
account and Emma so we're going to do
with all the challenges of the globe
we've got to have relationships with
everyone
mr. yang we're trying to squeeze in a
couple more things before we go to
another break mystery in China we need
to cooperate with them on climate change
ai you know there are issues North Korea
thanks for the quickness memo to do we
have no idea which are our most our
relationship with the entire world needs
to change and it starts by modeling
American values at fault okay mr. vice
president trying to be quick we know
NATO will fall apart if he's elected
four more years as a single most
consequential alliance of United States
senator Sanders it's not one country I
think it is rebuilding trust in the
United Nations and understand that we
can solve conflicts without war but with
diplomacy senator Harris all the members
of the NATO alliance
senator Gillibrand president Trump is
hell-bent on starting a war with Iran
I first will be to engage Iran to
stabilize the Middle East and make sure
we can start and unwanted never ending
war senator Bennet quickly our European
allies in every latin-american country
that's willing to have a conversation
about how to deal with a refugee and
Congressman swallow my first act in
foreign policy we're breaking up with
Russia and making up with NATO's thank
you all thank you all last question for
Vice President Biden tonight you have
made your decades of experience and
foreign policy a pillar of your campaign
but when the time came to say yes or no
on one of the most consequential foreign
policy decisions of the last century you
voted for the Iraq war you have since
said you regretted that vote but why
should voters trust your judgment when
it comes to making a decision about
taking the country because he's older
and smarter because once we once the
Bush abused that power
what happened was we got elected after
that I made sure the president turned to
me and said Joe get our combat troops
out of Iraq I was responsible for
getting 150,000 combat troops out of
Iraq and my son and what was one of them
I also think we should not have combat
troops in Afghanistan it's long overdue
it should end and I thirdly
I believe that you're not gonna find
anybody who has pulled together more of
alliances to deal with what is the real
stateless threat out there we cannot go
to lone in terms of dealing with
terrorism
so I'd eliminate the the the act that
allowed us to go into war and not the
AUMF and make sure that it could only be
used for what it's intended would what's
intense was and that is to go after
terrorists but never do it alone that's
why I have to repair our alliances we've
put together 65 countries to make sure
we dealt with Isis in Iraq and other
places that's what I would do that's
what I have done and I know how to do it
senator Sanders's
not terrible but it's not great one of
the differences that Joe and I have been
our record is Joe voted for that war I
helped lead the opposition to that was
Ron Bernie master second of all I helped
lead the effort for the first time to
utilize the War Powers Act to get the
United States out of the saudi-led
intervention in Yemen which is the most
horrific
right Terry
and thirdly strengthen it be very clear
I will do everything I can to prevent a
war with Iran which would be far worse
than disastrous war good news is you get
more time to talk but I have to sneak in
one more break okay so bernie is
actually coming on strong now towards
the end he has not been great I still
think Kamala Harris is the one who
benefits the most from this particularly
if she can close with a with a strong
closing statement and given her
prosecutorial experience I am sure she
is going to close with a very strong
closing statement but Bernie now is
actually in the running with Budaj edge
sort of for second place in this thing
I'm getting a ton of messages from
people saying the david pakman show
website is down and they can't sign up
for membership the website has been
completely overwhelmed by new members
I have rebooted the website and it seems
to be running and much more quickly now
so that has been done I want to say
thanks to Kelly hive Li and David Levitt
and Remy davits Divya to Abhishek Vasu
and Charlie Chuck Mullenix kyle gallup
charles fernandez albert direct o david
robbins i mentioned already
very very excited to see all of those
names coming in also if you are watching
today and you are not a subscriber to
the david pakman show youtube channel we
have six hundred and seventy one
thousand subscribers i would love to
earn your subscription as well if you've
enjoyed the commentary or even if you
just have enjoyed the stream and you'd
rather me not talk much but you
appreciate that we're here doing this
hit the subscribe button down below last
time I mentioned this the subscriber
number popped by like 400 so please hit
that subscribe button I know a lot of
the 16,000 of you are not currently
subscribers to the show and if you
really want to see things get crazy and
you're new to the David Pakman show as
soon as this debate ends I'm opening the
phone lines at 6 178 3 0 47 50 I'll
mention it a few minutes before the
debate wraps so people can start calling
in I will take phone calls it could be
trolls it could be people who disagree
with me
agree with me whatever we are going to
hear from some of the folks in the
audience the number will be six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
and I do hope that you stick around for
that but still I guess there's probably
one more topic and then maybe closing
statements although maybe they'll go
right to closing statements hit that
subscribe button use the info right
there to sign up for a membership people
who are wondering what my streaming
setup is I have a story right now on my
Instagram account at David Pakman check
it out it's the only story I think
that's up right now and you can see the
various the array of screens that is in
front of me and what I'm looking at in
the chat and all of these different
things I just posted that and we will
get back to the debate the last few
minutes of this Part B of debate one
[Music]
[Applause]
each candidate will have a final chance
to make their case to the voters 45
seconds each finals begin with Congress
and sois well we can't be a
forward-looking party if we look to the
past for our leadership I'm a
congressman but also a father of a
two-year-old at an infant when I'm not
changing diapers I'm changing Washington
most the time the diapers smell better I
went to Congress at 31 and I found a
Washington that doesn't work for people
like you and me it's made of the rich in
the disconnected I was the first of my
family to go to college and have student
loan debt so I have led the effort to
elect the next generation of members of
Congress and we have a moment to seize
this is a can-do generation this is the
generation that will end climate chaos
this is the generation that will solve
student loan debt and this is the
generation that will say enough is
enough
an end gun violence this generation
demands bold solutions that's why I'm
running for president congressman thank
you we haven't talked more tonight about
how we're going to beat Donald Trump no
that's good talk about issues Donald
Trump is not going to be beaten just by
insider politics talk he's not going to
be beaten just by somebody who has plans
he's going to be beaten by somebody who
has an idea what this man has done this
man has reached into the psyche of the
American people and he's harnessed fear
for political purposes so mr. president
if you're listening I want you to hear
me please you have harnessed fear for
political purposes and only love can
cast that out so I sir I have a feeling
you know what you're doing I'm going to
harness love for political purposes I
will meet you on that field and sir love
will win and on that note she will be
out of the race give him seven days I am
opening the phone
he played penholder my mom and her
parents came to the United States to
rebuild their shattered lives 300
country that they could three hundred
years before that my parents family came
searching religious freedom here the
ability for one generation to do better
than the next is now severely at risk
the United States especially among
children living in poverty like the ones
I used to work for in the Denver Public
Schools that's why I'm running for
president I've had two tough races in
Colorado by bringing people together not
by making empty promises and I believe
we need to build a broad coalition of
Americans to beat Donald Trump and the
corruption in Washington and build a new
era of American democracy and American
opportunity this is going to be hard to
do but it's what our parents would have
expected it's what our kids deserve I
hope that join me in this effort thank
you thank you come on I reckon I'm a
small business owner who brought that
same scrappy spirit to big Colorado one
of the most progressive states in
America we expanded reproductive health
to to reduce teenage abortion by 64
percent we were the first state to
legalize marijuana and we transformed
our justice system in the process we
passed universal background checks in a
purple state we got to near universal
health care coverage we attacked climate
change with the toughest methane
regulations in the country and for the
last three years we've been the number
one economy in America you don't need
big government to do big things I know
that because I'm the one person up here
who's actually done the big progressive
things everyone else is talking about if
we turn towards socialism we run the
risk of helping to realize that
circumcision Thank You governor
women in America women in America are on
fire we've marched we've organized
we've run for office and we've won but
our rights are under attack like never
before by President Trump and the
Republicans who want to repeal roe v
wade which is why I went to the
frontlines in Georgia to fight for them
as president I will take on the fights
that no one else will I stood up to the
Pentagon and repealed Don't Ask Don't
Tell I've stood up to the banks and
voted against the bailout twice I've
stood up to Trump more than any other
senator in the US Senate and I have the
most comprehensive approach for getting
money out of politics with publicly
funded elections to deal with political
corruption now is not the time to play
it safe now it's not the time to be
afraid of first we need a president who
will take on the big challenges even if
she stands alone join me in fighting for
this senator gillibrand thank you you
have 45 seconds for your closing first I
want to thank everyone who put me on
this stage tonight I am proof that our
democracy still works
Democrats and Americans around the
country you have one question for their
nominee and that is who can be Donald
Trump
in 2020 that is the right question and
the right candidate to beat Donald Trump
will be solving the problems I got
Donald Trump elected and will have a
vision of a trickle up economy that is
already drawing thousands of disaffected
Trump voters conservatives independents
and libertarians as well as Democrats
and progressives I am that candidate I
can build a much broader coalition don't
know that I would have worded it that
way it is not right it is forward and
that is where I'll take the country in
2020 mr. yang thank you
[Applause]
for sure thank you uh I just want to
leave you with a couple of things one we
need a nominee who has the ability to
prosecute the case against four more
years of Donald Trump and I will do that
second this election is about you this
is about your hopes and your dreams and
your fears and what wakes you up at
three o'clock in the morning and that's
why I have what I call a three a.m.
agenda that is about everything from
what we need to do to deliver health
care to how you will be able to pay the
bills by the end of the month and when I
think about what our country needs I
promise you I will be a president who
leads with a sense of dignity with
honesty speaking the truth and giving
the American family all that they need
to get through the end of the month in a
way that allows them to prosper so I
hope to own earn your support please
join us at Comley here to work senator
thank you the closest treatment I give
you the weakest part of the night
nothing about politics is theoretical
for me I've had the experience of
writing a letter to my family putting it
in an envelope marked just in case and
leaving it where they would know where
to find it in case I didn't come back
from Afghanistan I've experienced of
being in a marriage that exists by the
grace of a single vote on the US Supreme
Court
I have the experience of guiding of
community where the per capita income
was below $20,000 when I took office
into a brighter future running because
the decisions we make in the next three
or four years are going to decide how
the next 30 or 40 go and when I get to
the current age of the current president
in the year 2050 five I want to be able
to look back on these years and say my
Genesis I've delivered climate solutions
racial equality and an end to endless
war help me deliver that new generation
to Washington before it's too late
thank you better poison
I suspect people all over the country
for watching this debate are saying
these are good people they have great
ideas but how come nothing really
changes how come for the last 45 years
wages have been stagnant for the middle
class how come we have the highest rate
of childhood poverty how come
45 million people still have student
debt how come three people are more
wealth than the bottom half of America
and here is the answer nothing will
change unless we have the guts to take
on Wall Street the insurance industry
the pharmaceutical industry the
military-industrial complex and the
fossil fuel industry if we don't have
the guts to take them on we'll continue
our plans
we'll continue to have talk and the rich
will get richer and everybody else will
be struggling 45 seconds thank you very
much I'm ready to lead this country
because I think it's important we
restore the soul of this nation this
president has ripped it out it's only
President our history who has equated
racist and and white supremacists with
ordinary and decent people he's the only
president who has backed engaged and
embraced dictators and Thunder knows
that our allies I'm secondly running for
president because I think we have to
restore the backbone of America the poor
and hard-working middle class people you
can't do that without replacing them
with the dignity they once had last
thing we got to unite the United States
America as much as anybody says we can
if we do there's not a single thing the
American people can't do this is the
United States of America we can do
anything if we're together together so
god bless you all and may God protect
our troops
[Applause]
this joint that I'm not going to thank
you
on a range of issues 20 candidates in
all we want to thank all the candidates
last night they say it takes guts to run
and stick your neck out like this to you
guys into the 10:00 last night like to
thank the audience for completely
ignoring our suggestion
[Applause]
thank you to everyone at the Adrienne
Arsht Center for hosting us here and our
terrific audience
all right so let's get right to the
phones and see what's on people's minds
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty I said I would take calls
and I am going to so people can start
calling in now I'm just gonna get myself
onto the phone system it looks like
there's already 40 or 50 people holding
but we will get to a variety of
different people
before you leave hit the subscribe
button subscribe on YouTube okay thanks
to the probably in total with the roll
over 30 or 40,000 people that watched
this livestream six one seven eight
three zero 47 50 is the number to call
to talk to me right now the website has
been reset so if you are trying to get a
membership it should be back up and
running I know it was down for a little
bit let's just get right to the phones
and see what people think here we'll
start with our caller from the eight one
six area code who's calling today from
eight one six go ahead this is Jordan I
wonder I'm like a yang supporter whoever
and I'm wondering like can yang come
back from this lackluster performance
yeah I know I was actually tweeting
during this thing and a bunch of people
were retweeting it saying well yeah he
is being too polite and I don't this was
his shot you know and I don't know that
this is we Andrew yang needed to get to
three or four percent as a result of
this debate and I don't know that this
performance gets him to three or four
percent I just don't all right man thank
you great barrage checking and
appreciate the call let's see I mean
let's just to just to do it because we
haven't heard from him for a while let's
get Jimmy from Philly on the phone and
see what's is on his mind Jimmy from
Philly what's going on Jimmy from Philly
hey della good how are you David how are
you you must be drunk it's 11:00 right
no I'm not drunk all right no I like
y'all all this tank
do you want to give me $1,000 a month a
thousand yeah uh-huh
so you're voting yes isn't that what he
said see how's an hours a month right
that was I love them
sorry vote again no I'm not appreciating
how many beers they're all the
candidates he's the only one who makes
any sense because he's talking about
giving me cash
okay so you like free stuff is what
you're saying I like cash and has Trump
giving you any yeah I got a raise this
year Trump gave you the raise that's
interesting yeah no Jimmy how many beers
have you had earlier I had a few but
yeah yeah how many I mean like I had a
few pocket drinks two so oh yeah how
many how many are there 12% ours do you
think you had I have any other oh okay
Jimmy very good anything else on the
agenda uh you know none of those clowns
are gonna be Trump very good okay it's
not gonna happen it's not gonna happen
David you and you know it everybody
knows it binds to frontrunner it doesn't
matter what Biden says or does he's
gonna be the nominee and Biden was a
joke tonight but you know you and I
agree Biden did not do well tonight and
I actually I wouldn't be surprised if
Biden is not leading the polls two weeks
from today because his performance was
truly not good right well we'll see okay
Jamie very good good to hear from you
I'm sure you've got our lady and all of
that stuff so we will we'll let you go
all right Jimmy very good Jimmy from
Philly let's see who else we've got here
let's go to oh I don't know I mean I'm
just going going crazy here with area
codes let's try let's try the people or
something's up with the phone system
there's almost
too many people holding let's try the
five six one area code who's calling
today from 561 hello yes that's you
great basically I have a question it's
really relating to the debate but I
wanted I called the way before and it
was it was I think it was mentioned on
your interview that joe rogan show and
it was about that we of that one woman
who try to get you fired from boston
college because you tweeted that it's
not progressive to vote for someone are
not vote for someone based off of their
race gender well you yeah yeah yeah I
said that excluding candidates merely
because of their race or gender is not
progressive and she tried to get me
fired from Boston College for saying
that right so what you said on the Joe
Rogan show and imply that what she was
saying was racist and I called asking
what you thought about that because
racism isn't applicable to white people
and I really wanted to hear yourself
from that because yeah who says you
can't be racist against white people
well okay we have to really take a look
at what racism is because if we're going
by the definition that it's
discriminating or seeing a race as above
or below another that's a very skewed
definition where racism should be
examining the social economic and
political system and within this nation
and other anglo-saxon ations
there's only one group the in-group
which are white people that have
political socio-economic power to
oppress no totally disagree with you I
think that's a losing let's that's a
losing redefinition of racism you can be
there's no question that power dynamics
are really important in thinking about
whether racism translates into
structural oppression but you can be
racist no matter what your races and no
matter what one other people's race is I
think it's exciting what you say is
extremely problematic
definition of problematic when it takes
into account the historical implications
of what white people have a group have
done to oppress people it's just not
it's just not the right it's just not
accurate you're the first definition you
gave is the right one and so I think
there's two things because it's not what
racism you're just you're coming up with
a new definition it's like if I said you
know well you've presented another
definition right and I think I'm
presenting the most accurate and
holistic definition of racism and that's
what so for you the most accurate
definition of racism is one in which no
one can be racist against white people
is that what you're saying that's what
you said that's how we started the
conversation you said you can't be
racist against white people
in Western anglo-saxon countries you
can't be racist
Alys in this nation in this and this
nation specifically because that's what
I studied with racism cessation
specifically you can't be racist to
white people because people of color
don't have the power okay hold on a
second just hold on one second okay let
me let's just take it let's let's build
it up if a Hispanic person says I don't
like white people because they're white
is that racist no it's not racist
however how does that know however just
how is it not racist it's not racist
because okay well I can't I can't say
Hispanic because Hispanic is an
ethnicity so I understand what you mean
by let's say a person of color a person
of color cannot be racist towards a
white person because they don't have the
power okay all right fine so look we're
going through just indulge me if a
person of color says I don't like white
people because of their whiteness that's
not racist according to you if they come
company says if a company says we are
not going to hire white people at this
company is that racist bigoted it's
racially bigoted really like I think
it's a slice of your left that you
represent is very small
but it is extremely problematic and I
completely disagree okay how do I want
to I follow you because I think you're
really reasonable and I subscribe to you
and I think it's great what you do and
what you're saying is extraordinarily
unreasonable Trust and a reason then
however one thing is not like some
conspiracy theorists idea it's not wrong
because we have people studying race and
racism for decades and anthropologists
have come together to you're just wrong
listen I'm I'm a Hispanic immigrant to
this country if I said I'm going to
enact it hold on a second why if you
really want to get down into ethnicity
I'm actually asking Ozzie but this is a
whole this is why this is so stupid if I
say no matter what my race is if I'm
white if I'm Hispanic if I'm Ashkenazi
if I said the David Pakman show is not
going to hire white people as a policy
because I just don't like having white
people around that is racist by any
definition of the word and any deviation
from prejudice but racism needs to take
the holistic definition of prejudice
plus power listen now you're just
playing now you're just playing semantic
games I'm gonna let you go cuz the
audience I think is tuning out but
you're just wrong I would urge you to
rethink your views and I hope that that
does not infect any of the Democratic
candidates dialog because that is self
to saying is a disaster it's it's it's
extraordinarily damaging and fortunately
I don't think it's super prevalent
because what you're saying doesn't make
any sense okay
well I mean I'm shocked by that I'm
shocked by that okay let's try another
call let's go to the let's go to the
2:00 to 4:00 area code who's calling
today from 2:00 to 4:00 oh yeah that's
you my name is Rome I'm calling from the
Chicago area hey Rome what's going
uh who would you say was what do you
think Bernie should have done to perform
better in this debate he I mean listen
part of it is just he got some questions
that were not the best suited questions
to him so like Elizabeth Warren was
lucky yesterday because the questions
she got were very well suited to her
strengths Bernie was a little bit low
energy I would have just liked to see
him a little more proactive
I don't think Bernie did poorly but he
was just sort of low energy he didn't
get the best questions for him but he
did have a strong closing and I can't
imagine I don't think he did any harm to
his campaign maybe a little bit actually
but um I think that it was just sort of
a low energy evening for him all right
thank you
all right very good let's see who else
do we have here let's try let's try the
405 area code who's calling today from
405 hey what's up man its Laramie hey
Laramie what's going on oh not too much
man the last two debates okay yep I've
only agreed with two things said and it
was closing statements okay it was
nuclear threat is the most prevalent
threat to the United States yep no
matter which country that comes from or
and what Bernie Sanders said today that
we had to take on the
military-industrial complex and the
stock markets okay because the people
who are running this country have all
the money and they part persecute us for
lesser things and what they do they kill
millions of people with like bad
prescription medications and get them
addicted to alcohol and cigarettes and
all that stuff right and I would like to
have your opinion on what would be the
best candidate to represent those issues
well I mean it depends on what your
approach is to dealing with those issues
a lot of what you're mentioning falls
under public health and the health care
system and I think that Bernie and
Warren are very strong on
that particular issue if you think that
the issues you're bringing up are more
law enforcement issues than maybe the
candidates someone else I don't know but
I'm hearing that mostly those are health
public health issues okay well hey I
just want to tell you one more thing
that yeah
God loves ya okay very good
so much appreciate everybody all right
let's see where do we want to go next
let's go to let's go to the 911 3 area
code who's calling today from nine one
three so yeah it's you me that's you
awesome so my question for you and
excuse me for a second because I just
lost it okay I'm nervous no problem so
my question for you is do you feel that
in the entirety of this campaign
Andrew gang is a strong candidate for
making America a better place for us not
necessarily in the polls or if he's
going to win but what is your opinion on
on Andrew Yang's policies and what he
could do for us I think Andrew yang is
pretty strong on domestic policy
although I disagree with the way he
would implement some of his ideas and
I've interviewed him three times and
I've talked to him about that that's no
secret I've not been super impressed by
Andrew Yang's foreign policy credentials
and and sort of chops but but he's also
not talked about that too much and
yesterday I was tweeting back back to
him to something he tweeted and I said
people end up in these debates often
looking stupid on foreign policy he
didn't end up really having to address
that too much but I can't really say on
foreign policy whether Andrew yang would
be how whether he would be good or not
good or somewhere in the middle yeah I
completely agree with you um could I
make one more question or yes or do you
want to move on now ahead um so do you
think that corruption in our government
ie giving you know lobbyist lobbying for
certain ideals and companies giving
politicians a ton of money yeah do you
think that level of corruption in our
country is a major issue and you need to
address it corruption is a major issue
in the United States but it's an issue
in a different way than it's an issue
for example what you might see and I
don't even want to give another example
because I don't want to single any
country out but the institutions in the
United States are less corrupt in many
ways than in many less developed
countries including some countries in
Latin America and Africa and you know
some people will know which countries
those are but that doesn't mean that
there is not just an inherent completely
corrosive and toxic cronyism and status
quo bias that is terrible in different
ways than the type of overt corruption
that exists in other countries so it's
different I think it's not as bad in
many ways but it doesn't mean that it
should be ignored or it's not a problem
right okay thank you so much all right
appreciate it thank you so much
great to hear from you make sure to
subscribe to the David Pakman show
YouTube channel it takes one second to
click subscribe down below it's really
great for us we've been getting crushed
lately by YouTube's algorithm and
bringing in a bunch of new subscribers
really helps us and it costs you nothing
let's go to our caller from the 9 to 0
area code who's calling today from 9 to
zero nine to zero you there 9 to zero is
gone ok let's try our caller from the
five six seven area code who's calling
today from five six seven yeah that's
you hey David this is Ethan from Ohio I
do anything what's going on good I was
wondering do you think that it was
calculated on Kamala Harris as part to
sort of go after Joe Biden and he also
think Joe Biden's sort of downfall in
the debate was inevitable I don't think
Joe Biden's downfall was inevitable I am
actually wondering whether he seemed to
be having a weird speech thing going on
where his speech seemed slow and a
little bit like that thing Trump had
happened that god bless the United
States of America
stuff I don't know what's going on
something weird was going on so that
that's one question I do think Kamala
Harris probably knew ahead of time
at some point she was going to go after
Joe Biden on the race stuff I think it
worked for her I mean listen yesterday
when Beto O'Rourke was asked what should
the top marginal tax rate be and he said
nuestro democracia I think it was a
totally disastrous disingenuous planned
thing to do
Kamala Harris probably had this plan of
at some point bringing this up with
Biden she did it at a time that seemed
relatively natural and it went pretty
well for her I would say yes thank you
all right take my car
my pleasure great thank you for calling
it appreciate it okay let's go to the
to10 area code two one zero is a
historically very dangerous area code
for this show two one zero what's going
on hello yeah that's you okay cool
hi I'm a longtime subscriber new time
first time ever a little nervous but no
problem um yeah do you want to say he
was kind of funny that you said like two
windows dangerous well yeah my name is
Fernando and up from Texas yeah yeah can
I make sense and um yeah I got a I agree
with you on the beta work messing up and
I was wondering what was your risk
Democratic candidate do you think has
the strongest foreign policy foreign
policy you know it really depends on
what region you're talking about so I
think that like for example who Leon
Castro is really strong on Central and
Latin America and immigration in a way
that many other candidates are not when
it comes to I don't know when it comes
to China I think that Elizabeth Warren
has some very good ideas and you know
interestingly I think this is a little
wacky but Delaney yesterday even though
he basically imploded like he seemed to
actually have some foreign policy
knowledge that was relevant I don't know
I'd really have to think about it bigger
picture in terms in terms of in which
area do I think each candidate is
strongest mm-hmm well thank you for that
I just want to say that like I feel like
the big winners from my opinion it's
definitely Kamala Harris and I want to
say beauty judge honestly I don't have
promise tonight yeah yeah from tonight
and Warren and Julian Castro that's the
way I have it yesterday I had it Warren
Castro and de Blasio as the three top
performers again this is like not based
on what I like them to say about the
policies I like this is just the way I
think these things are evaluated and
tonight I think Harris is the definite
winner Budaj edge probably number two
maybe tied with Bernie and then I
actually I don't know where I go next
I actually thought Bennett even though
he said some really wacky things had
some strong moments although he's got no
chance and should probably get out of
the race immediately there were a lot of
weak performers tonight yeah yeah I feel
like the first night was way stronger in
terms of like people putting out their
ideas and policies and just tonight was
just a lot of platitudes it was just a
lot of appealing to feeling yeah I agree
with you all right thanks very much
great to hear from you hope to hear from
you again and really appreciate the
phone call okay two-one-zero is gone all
right let's do something different let's
see if we can conference in a few
viewers with each other so let's see let
me bring in oh this should be
interesting
let me bring on valve from Agawam first
Val are you with us tonight
hi David are you doing hey Val what's
going on
I'm doing well good so stand by with me
I'm gonna add into the feed here we've
not done this before just because it's a
very special night let's add in Brody
from now okay great Brody can you hear
me David I can't hear you Brody and Val
two past callers to the David Pakman
show please
Val I want you to take the question from
Brody and let's see what he had to say
today Brody go ahead my question
actually comes down to how are we going
to phrase and give our message
about that the overall cost to benefit
ratio with regards to health care mm-hmm
I think Bernie stumbled on a little bit
he kind of said hey we are gonna raise
taxes but he didn't make it clear enough
that look this is going to cost you less
in the long run and be better for you
right so now I want to know how do we
how do we get our messaging on point
because yeah those Republicans got
they're gonna very good question Val can
you address this issue how can we better
explain how you are at a care for all
Rodi Rodi in it
yes it's Brody yeah Brody these are my
thoughts
I thought Bernie was a little bit too
polite tonight I've seen many of his
rallies and he does go into a lot of
depth about how to handle the cost of
Medicare and he talks about the other
countries of the world that have systems
where it's single-payer and where their
health care is better and it isn't
costing them as much and I was a little
surprised he didn't go into more detail
tonight I think that would be the best
thing to do all the times that you've
heard him how easily is he able to
distill that though the times that I've
heard him like I said have been at
rallies I wish he sort of maybe would
have pretended in his mind that he was
at a rally and out of the debate and
maybe he would have been not as timid
about it um interesting I know David
have you ever have you seen any of it
I've seen Bernie be much clearer about
this whole thing of listen there will be
attacks but the tax will be way smaller
than all of the things you're already
paying for including premiums and your
part I just think he was less clear
about let's do this
let's bring in sebastian to see if he
can shed insight into Brody's question
to bow sebastian have you been listening
to this and what do you think about what
they're saying yeah I agree with
proposal you said you do okay
we should take an angle of like there's
a hidden tax like because there is a
hidden tax of not how we you know what
I'm sorry it must it must have skipped
when I got
connected I didn't hear that part oh
dear okay that's interesting you know I
think the only solution to this is that
we pull Vivek in Vivek what do you think
about Sebastian's opinion about how
they'll handled the question from breda
all day I didn't expect to be here
caught in like hey so as far as a
Bernese appeal is concerned that's what
we're talking about right like how he
can yeah how can he better as a clan
that or will be a tax for Medicare for
all but it's a net savings overall yeah
I think he should lead off by saying
like it's in that savings I think the
way that he went about addressing some
of the questions like for example the
one where they asked him like what is
the one policy you'd put into place like
right now if you're president it sounded
like he was kind of trying to dodge the
questions and I don't think that's the
best strategy he should start off just
by saying I think the way that like Kyle
kolinsky would say she would just say
like it saves money it saves money for
the American people and then like go
over briefly on how it does that
yeah I would just open I would say
listen this is a net savings we're
taking away a bunch of costs we're
adding a small payroll tax and overall
we're going to be saving a lot of money
because this is going to be a system
that overall is going to reduce the cost
for caring for each person over the
course of a year
what about ik weighting it like this is
starting out saying look with the
current system you pay more and you get
less and with medicare-for-all or a
universal system it's the opposite like
should we approach it from that angle
because I think that's interesting but I
think it's just like we want to make it
as simple as possible and that's not the
simplest possible way to talk about it
that is true Sebastian are you pleased
with the direction of this conversation
[Laughter]
okay go ahead I'm in it so lemme see I'm
in at Brody great to hear from you we're
gonna let Brody go Val always great to
hear from you and appreciate the phone
call from Val and let's Vivek you're
still on with me but let's hear from
Sebastian's question here
I'll translate okay kiddo mm-hmm CD when
the Joseph Ellie came to live with he
mustered custody on a servant anatomy
learning less you can use photomask in
extreme area chicanery on Terra medium
can tell is a Canadian citizen
Universitario Lisa Nathaniel Samantha a
convenient annulus key crew el Parian
trabajo y okay physic do you want to
handle this one Oh should I give like a
better response and respond on like a
broken Spanish as I took it on like
eighth grade yeah yeah like better
yesterday
to do bilingual dubbing of the David
Pakman show we're thinking there's a
very interesting project going on in at
a university I don't even know if it's
public where a machine learning system
can take the captions from the David
Pakman show in English and spit out an
audio track in a bunch of other
languages and it's like it's pretty good
and my mouth moves and you hear Spanish
or you hear Japanese or the two that
I've seen so far
so right now Sebastian was asking about
a job and that he would work for very
cheap right now it's crazy because it's
automation it would be a computer
program that would be doing that so
there's not currently any jobs available
but if there are we always announce it
on the show and listed on the website
all right thanks
okay Sebastian thank you appreciate the
phone call okay and then Vivek what was
actually the topic of your phone call
well I mean I did take a class on the
street learning so if you want me to do
that you could pay me a ten million
dollars and I'll do it okay on so yes
where is my question so considering like
the results of the debate tonight it was
no secret that comma didn't really well
and but it didn't do very well
yes do you think that there's like a
chance that
dnc might actually get behind calm allah
and look abandoned joe budden and if so
like how would a Bernie best combat her
I don't think that the DNC anytime soon
is going to abandon Biden but I think
from the before Biden was running it
seemed as though
Kamala would was sort of the de-facto
establishment DNC anointed candidate and
I think that if Joe Biden I hope he's
not having a health issue but something
was very strange from what was going on
today if he starts dropping in the polls
or whatever I do believe that canola is
is probably the default for the DNC or
Buddha jej Buddha judge has reportedly
been have been attending the stop Bernie
meetings that insiders in the DNC a big
Democratic donors rather have been
having so I think it's Buddha Jagger
Kamala okay so yeah I mean like Biden
looks like he was about to start crying
when he was being decorated by Tom Ellis
I was thinking like maybe if he dropped
out or something
da face really not a coward Bernie fight
against Allah yeah I I don't know that I
we need to worry about what Bernie
strategy would be because I think that
the DNC shifting from Biden to Kamala if
Biden starts declining is going to be
terrible for the establishment candidate
whoever it ends up being and I think in
that interim Bernie and probably Warren
would pick up a lot of polling support
anyway so I don't even know that we have
to think about it as how would Bernie
fight Kamala I think if the DNC abandons
Biden and goes to someone else that in
and of itself will be very damaging for
whoever that candidate is okay thanks
great to hear from you we currently have
something like 90 people holding and
this is probably we pay for everybody
who's holding and we probably have spent
several hundred dollars in this evening
taking phone calls and I've got to go to
bed because we've got a Friday show so
we're gonna wrap thanks to everybody who
joined me hugely successful stream
dozens of new members a lot of very very
crazy stuff went on but we will
definitely continue streaming live
debates and I'll be back with full
analysis of the David Pakman show of the
debate on the David Pakman show tomorrow
before you leave hit that subscribe
button down below
really helps us on the path to 700
and subscribers